[musique]
Natacha Polini, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
On vous reçoit pour votre deuxième fois
chez nous.
Ouais.
2 ans après. On vous avait reçu il y a 2
ans pour le comité Horwell.
Exactement.
Qu'est-ce que ça a donné ? Qu'est-ce que
ça donne ?
Ça continue. C'est-à-dire que bon pour
des raisons hélas de bonne camaraderie
entre journalistes, ça ne s'appelle plus
le comité Orwell, ça s'appelle les
Orwelliens. Nous avons été obligés de
changer de nom au moment où nous avons
lancé au moment où on a lancé la ma web
télé qui au départ était enfin
s'appelait Orwell TV. On avait choisi
parce que pour moi c'était la
continuité. On avait choisi de l'appeler
comme ça parce que on c'était ce qui
nous rassemblait, c'était juste
justement le pas seulement la critique
du totalitarisme par George Orwell, mais
la le aussi la dimension socialiste, euh
un socialisme patriotique. Enfin, il y
avait tout ça, c'est il y avait une
cohérence. Et puis le jour du lancement,
euh des collaborateurs du monde des
livres puis de Libé et cetera ont
passé la journée à essayer de retrouver
les ayants droits de George Orwell
qu'ils ont réussi à trouver. Et donc
nous avons reçu une mise en demeure au
bout de 24 heures donc de l'avocat des
ayants droits nous disant qu'on avait
pas le droit d'utiliser le nom. Donc
nous avons précipitamment changé de nom.
Donc et là s'il a fallu abandonner et
trouver un nom tout de suite, c'est pour
ça qu'on a appelé ça Polonie TV. Je
trouve ça moins bien. C'est plus simple
en référencement internet mais ça gomme
la dimension collective du travail et
c'est et c'est dommage. Mais voilà. Bref
bref nous en sommes là. Nous ont
travaillé, nous ont comment dire avancé
Polonie TV qui est qui diffuse donc des
vidéos, on en met en ligne à peu près
deux par jour, des éditaux, des
entretiens, des choses qui permettent de
d'aborder des sujets qui nous semblent
absolument essentiels et qui sont très
rarement abordés ou pas forcément comme
nous le voudrions dans les dans les
médias plus classiques, plus
traditionnels,
notamment sur les questions économiques
parce que comme je l'avais déjà dit sur
le comité Orwell, on a beaucoup de
journalistes économiques parce que c'est
le sujet où sans doute il y a le moins
de liberté dans les médias, le moins de
pluralisme, le moins de possibilité de
mettre en avant certaines certaines
réflexions. Donc quelqu'un comme
Jean-Michel 4 points qui était fondateur
de du comité Orwell et qui est à Polonie
TV fait des vidéos sur des sujets. par
exemple, il a été l'un des premiers à
alerter sur la la réforme fiscale de
Donald Trump sur la façon dont il
fallait se préparer à ce qui est une
un bouleversement des données des règles
de la fiscalité qui va avoir un impact
sur sur nous en Europe et il a fallu un
temps fou pour que je trouve dans la
presse papier ou dans les médias
téléaudiovisuels
un début de réflexion sur ces questionsl
comment vous l'expliquez
parce que les médias
classique
plutôt ont préférait axer sur la
personnalité de Donald Trump, expliquer
qu'il était méchant, qu'il était
raciste, qu'il était vulgaire, ce qui
est sans doute vrai, mais on s'en fiche,
je c'est pas le problème. Et je pense
que sur les questions de géopolitique et
d'économie, il y a une espèce de prisme
qui est parfois un peu un peu
moutonnier, qui consiste à ne surtout
pas chercher à décrypter la les rapports
de force. C'est qu'il y a un oubli de la
notion de rapport de force.
C'est moutonnier ou c'est de la
forfeture ? Est-ce que c'est de la
trahison ? Est-ce que vous pensez que
nos médias sont sous influence de
puissance extérieure ?
Non, enfin non, je je ne verrai pas les
choses comme ça d'abord parce que je
pense qu'il faut distinguer entre les
structures et les individus et que je
pense qu'il y a surtout une façon de
traiter l'actualité qui est impliquée
par la forme de ces médias, que ce soit
les journaux, la télévision, la radio et
qui modèle la façon dont les
journalistes vont essayer de faire leur
travail et même s'ils essayent de le
faire le mieux possible, ils sont pris
dans une dans une façon d'agir. et de
traiter l'information qui parfois leur
interdit ce de d'aller vers les
véritables sujets. Et sur les questions
économiques, je suis frappée surtout par
la le fait que je pense que beaucoup de
compétences se sont perdues.
C'est-à-dire que il y avait dans les
années 80
une spécialisation des journalistes qui
leur donnait une capacité à peser face à
leurs interlocuteurs. Ils connaissaient
leur sujet, il le dominaient aussi bien
que les chefs d'entreprise qu'ils
avaient en face d'eux que les voilà et
petit à petit, on a cassé cette
compétence en faisant en organisant un
roulement au sein des journaux en en
estimant qu'il fallait mettre en avant
avant tout le l'investigation et non pas
la connaissance que le journaliste avait
du milieu dans lequel il opérait. Et je
pense que il y a une déperdition du
savoir-faire, du métier et sur les
questions économiques, il faut connaître
les sujet dont on parle. on peut pas
s'improviser. Mais d'ailleurs, c'est
vrai aussi dans d'autres sujets parce
que dans le domaine qui était le mien,
le questions d'éducation, je pense que
il faut avoir une très bonne
connaissance du système, de son
fonctionnement, des prismes idéologiques
pour pouvoir traiter les choses et ne
pas être ne pas être comment dire
dépendant de la des outils de
communication des gens qu'on a en face
de soi. Donc il me semble que ça plus
disons une espèce d'habitude qui
consiste à systématiquement
accepter les dogmes qui sont fixés par
les les médias dominants et par le
finalement l'ensemble du milieu politico
médiatique. Ça donne une espèce de
d'incapacité à traiter les sujets. Je
pense par exemple sur les questions de
libre échange et de protectionnisme. On
le voit actuellement avec la la question
de la fameuse guerre commerciale lancée
par Donald Trump.
le l'espèce de réflexe qui consiste à
dire le protectionnisme c'est la guerre,
donc il faut défendre le libre échange
qui euh est tellement merveilleux et qui
nous garantit la paix me semble un
réflexe assez euh comment dire assez
primaire dans le sens où la question
n'est pas de de distinguer entre le
blanc et le noir, d'expliquer qu'il y
aurait d'un côté le protectionnisme avec
des barrières, des frontières et de
l'autre le libre échange généralisé qui
serait forcément le bien. Il y a pas
ouverture et fermeture. Il faut essayer
de comprendre ce que le libre échange a
provoqué, comment il s'est construit,
qui en profite, pourquoi moi quand
j'entends chez Jingping aller à Davos
donner des leçons de libre échange à
l'ensemble du monde et expliquer que
c'est formidable et qu'il faut défendre
le libre échange, je pense qu'on
pourrait avoir un tout petit peu de
recul vis-à-vis de ça. Alors, je suis
très frappée de voir à quel point
beaucoup de de médias reprennent
l'espèce de oui de vulgate selon
laquelle bah le protectionnisme ça
conduit à la guerre. Donc il faut aimer
le libre échange qui est merveilleux et
on n entre jamais dans la nuance des
choses dans la dans le disons le minimum
de recul qui permettrait de ne pas être
prisonnier des oppositions binaires.
On on dit que il faut donner au public
ce qu'il veut et non pas ce que nous on
a envie de leur donner. C'est ça.
Est-ce que vous pensez que les gens euh
n'ont plus cette capacité à comprendre
leur système économique et que les
journalistes leur donnent simplement une
vulgate simple à comprendre ?
Alors, je il y a il y a deux problèmes
dans votre question.
Il y a d'abord la question de savoir
s'il faut donner aux gens ce qu'ils
veulent, ce qui en matière de médias me
semble totalement erroné parce que
la phrase n'est pas de moi,
je sais bien mais la le
la question de savoir si il est
démocratique de donner aux gens ce
qu'ils attendent est une question
absolument cruciale.
On va y revenir. La deuxième partie de
la de la question
là aussi pose problème en elle-même.
C'est-à-dire que
je ne pense pas que
on donne aux gens en matière économique
ce qu'ils attendent. Au contraire, on
essaie de les rééduquer et c'est ça qui
me pose problème. On essaie de leur
expliquer que euh ils croient
spontanément que euh de la protection et
de la régulation permettrait de rétablir
une forme de justice. Et bien on va leur
expliquer que ce n'est pas vrai, que au
contraire il faut accepter le
la mondialisation telle qu'elle se
construit, c'est-à-dire sur une base
dérégulée parce que contrairement à tout
ce qu'ils ont autour d'eux,
contrairement à ce que leur dit le réel,
et bien c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça et
ça va permettre la croissance un jour et
ça va permettre des lendemains qu'il
chante. Or, je pense que cette forme de
discours qui consiste à dire "Ce que
vous voyez n'existe pas et nous allons
vous expliquer ce qui est bon pour vous
et le contraire de la démocratie." Et
c'est pour ça que j'en reviens à la
question, à la première partie de la
question. Faut-il donner aux gens ce
qu'ils attendent ? La question n'est pas
de leur donner ce qu'ils attendent ou de
les rééduquer. On n' pas le choix entre
les deux.
Le travail médiatique est un travail de
participation au processus démocratique,
me semble-t-il. C'est-à-dire qu'il
s'agit de construire
une information, de donner de décrire le
monde tel qu'il est le plus honnêtement
possible, de donner les clés,
c'est-à-dire non pas seulement de se
contenter de présenter des faits, mais
aussi de permettre de comprendre ses
faits parce que les faits en eux-mêmes
ne suffisent pas. Il y a aussi tout le
récit autour de ces faits et il faut le
faire de façon à ce que chez celui qui
écoute, qui lit puisse se construire une
réflexion et un libre arbitre.
C'est-à-dire qu'il puisse lui-même
construire son argumentation. Donc il ne
s'agit pas de le rééduquer, il ne s'agit
surtout pas de lui donner des réflexes.
Or, c'est ce que font beaucoup de médias
aujourd'hui. Ils estiment que euh leur
rôle est de dire le bien
et de faire en sorte que le public pense
bien. Il ne me semble pas que ce soit ça
notre rôle de journaliste. Je pense que
notre rôle de journaliste est de
construire du débat, de faire en sorte
que chaque citoyen puisse penser le
monde et puisse ensuite exercer son
rôle. au sein de la démocratie. Encore,
faudrait-il qu'il y ait réellement
ensuite tout le reste du processus
démocratique. Alors bien sûr, les médias
sont des entreprises, donc ils doivent
aussi
faire en sorte d'avoir des lecteurs,
d'avoir des téléspectateurs. Donc ils ne
peuvent pas prendre totalement leur
public à rebrousse-poil. Donc c'est un
équilibre complexe. Moi, j'ai le
souvenir d'avoir commencé dans le
journalisme avec donc à Marianne avec
Jean-François Cann qui me disait
toujours "Écoutez euh c'est très gentil
vos 14 pages sur euh l'école et cetera."
Voilà. Mais vous êtes dans un jour
pas sur le service public là, c'est ça ?
Non, c'était pas ça qu'il disait. Il
disait "On est dans un journal où il y a
des pages de fait d'hiver, vous trouvez
ça vulgaire, vous trouvez ça bête." où
il y a des des pages euh avec des
petites brèves humoristiques, ça
s'appelait tu l'adiboufi les pages. Vous
trouvez ça nul ? Écoutez, quand vous
regardez regardez dans le métro les gens
qui lisent Mariane, ils lisent en
priorité ça. Donc ils viennent pour ça
et du coup après ils vont lire vos 14
pages sur l'éducation. Et c'est parce
que vous êtes allé les chercher là où
ils étaient qu'ensuite vous allez
pouvoir leur faire lire vos 14 pages du
moment qu'elles sont écrite de façon
éminemment pédagogique, c'est-à-dire de
façon claire et non pas pour vos
confrères journalistes ou pour vous
faire mousser dans votre milieu. Voilà,
c'est-à-dire et ce processus là est très
important et il expliquait aussi quelque
chose qu'on retrouve chez chez Charles
Pegy. Charles Peggy disait une revue
doit mécontenter 1/5 de ses de ses
lecteurs. Mais il faut jamais que ce
soit le même 5e. Et Jean-François Cann
me disait exactement la même chose. En
gros, un journal doit évidemment
contenter plus de 50 % de ses lecteurs,
sinon les gens l'achètent plus. Voilà,
il doit leur leur donner en partie
quelque chose qui va leur plaire, qui va
les intéresser. Mais sur le reste, il
doit les choquer, il doit les bousculer,
il doit les prendre à contrepied, il
doit aller les chercher là où il pensait
pas qu'on allait qu'on irait les
chercher.
Ce que font les Russes maintenant.
Alors, [grognement] c'est
encore un peu différent comme processus.
C'est encore c'est pas exactement la
même chose. Disons qu'il s'agit,
je pense, d'essayer de ne pas flatter
son public dans le sens où on croit
qu'il va aller et qu'il faut au
contraire le surprendre, parfois aller
contre son intuition parce qu'on croit
que c'est que c'est juste et que c'est
la vérité. Ça ne et ça ça signifie qu'il
faut en permanence pour être capable de
penser parfois contre son public, penser
contre soi-même aussi et toujours
remettre en question les certitudes
qu'on a soi-même parce que sinon on est
incapable de remettre en cause les
certitudes d'un public qui est habitué à
ce qu'on dit. Voilà. Donc je pense que
c'est ce travail là qui doit être en
permanence celui des des médias, qui
devrait être celui des médias
aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire ne jamais
penser par réflexe, mais essayer en
permanence de remettre en cause ce qui
semble une évidence ou une certitude et
coupler ça avec un principe de valeur
ajoutée. C'est-à-dire l'idée que si il
s'agit de dire la même chose que ce que
disent tous les autres, ça n'a aucun
intérêt. C'est même pas la peine de
traiter le sujet.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du média ?
Je pense que le média euh part d'une
envie qui est tout à fait juste qui est
cette idée d'apporter du pluralisme dans
le paysage audiovisuel français qui est
c'est un Polonie TV de gauche.
Alors Polonie TV essaie d'avoir un
prisme qui est justement beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus large. C'estd que si vous
interrogez les journalistes de Polonie
TV, je pense que sur le prisme de ce
qu'ils peuvent voter de leur tendance
idéologique, c'est très très vaste.
C'est pour ça que je je crois que un
média doit essayer de travailler à son
propre pluralisme, même si il y a une
ligne dans chaque média et ce serait
stupide de le nier. Et je pense que ceux
qui essayent de faire croire qu'ils sont
dans l'objectivité pure se plantent
complètement parce qu'il est au
contraire très bon d'avoir conscience de
sa propre subjectivité. Donc il y a une
ligne mais autour de cette ligne, il
faut s'obliger au pluralisme parce que
c'est ça justement qui permet à un
médiat de penser contre lui-même et de
parfois de se surprendre, de d'aller à
contrepied de ce qui semblerait évident.
Or, il me semble que le média, malgré sa
son envie de pratiquer ce pluralisme,
pour l'instant ne n'atteint pas
forcément ce but, cet objet, même s'il y
a des des séquences que moi je trouve
très intéressantes hein, que ce soit le
travail d' Gael Brustier, enfin il y a
au média quelqu'un que j'aime énormément
et qui travaille à Polonie TV qui est
Kevin Victoire qui travaille aussi sur
le site la revue Le Comptoir qui est une
revue absolument formidable. Donc il y a
de un potentiel et des gens qui
travaillent très bien.
Les fake news, quand on voit euh des
choses comme le décodex,
sortir du bois pour être un phare dans
l'océan de l'internet, payer un peu par
Facebook euh si je crois bien. Et euh on
fait comment ? Euh du moins l'esprit
critique français fait comment avec des
fake news de plusieurs états, que ce
soit vers l'est ou vers l'ouest ?
Qu'est-ce que les journalistes ont comme
responsabilité ? dans ce problème.
Alors, je pense que la question des fake
news mérite beaucoup plus que les
slogans qu'on entend euh ces derniers
temps. C'est-à-dire que maintenant, à
chaque fois que euh une
qu'un problème se pose dans les médias à
chaque fois que quelqu'un aimait une
idée qui nous déplaît, fake news est
devenu le terme qui permet de
discréditer, de disqualifier.
J'aimerais qu'on me définisse ce terme.
Ça permettrait déjà d'éviter qu'il soit
instrumentalisé politiquement pour
prévoir de créer une loi qui déciderait
ce qui est vrai et ce qui ne l'est pas.
Je trouve ça profondément dangereux.
Pourquoi ? Parce que au départ, si on
prend la définition première de ce
qu'est une fake news,
c'est il me semble que il s'agit donc
d'une fausse information, une fausse
information qui serait diffusée et que
des gens pourraient croire vrai parce
qu'elle est faite pour sembler vrai. Ça
a toujours existé. Toujours, je veux
dire la manipulation et la
désinformation a toujours existé.
Peut-être que les réseaux sociaux
donnent aujourd'hui plus de poids à
cela, mais on ne peut pas dire que ce
soit une grande nouveauté quant à la
manipulation politique pour essayer de
déstabiliser des adversaires ou pour
essayer de déstabiliser même un état. Là
aussi, le moins qu'on puisse dire, c'est
que ça a toujours existé.
Donc ce terme de fake news a émergé dans
l'espace médiatique
à l'occasion de la campagne électorale
américaine. Il s'agissait d'expliquer
que
en gros derrière les affirmations
fausses et totalement délirantes parfois
de Donald Trump, il y avait une volonté
de déstabilisation
et une puissance étrangère.
Je pense que attribuer à la Russie la
victoire de Donald Trump à l'élection
américaine me semble quand même d'un
simplisme absolu. Ça permet d'éviter de
remettre en cause toute la politique qui
a mené à l'élection de Donald Trump et
tous les échecs qui ont mené. C'est
d'autant plus drôle que maintenant on
voit la Russie derrière absolument tout.
Moi, quand j'entends que même en
Catalogne, ce serait la Russie qui
aurait manipulé, enfin on se mar euh
pourquoi pas les élections Corse non
plus. Enfin, c'est je pense que certes,
il y a des manipulations, certes, il y a
des entreprises de diffusion de fausses
informations, mais hélas ce n'est pas ça
qui explique l'avèement de
d'insurrection par le vote tel qu'on les
a vu depuis quelques années. Je pense
qu'il serait beaucoup plus sain
d'essayer de comprendre ce qui dans le
système économique euh mondial explique
l'espèce de désarrois dans lequel se
trouvent les populations des pays
occidentaux. Donc les fake news, voilà,
c'est une espèce de l'heure pour éviter
de penser les questions politiques et la
façon dont on a abandonné la politique
en en la mettant sous le boissau pour
permettre au système économique de se
perpétuer. Donc je pense que aujourd'hui
les fake news sont utilisées pour
essayer de enfin le terme fake news est
utilisé pour essayer de faire terire
toute personne qui
tout simplement ne serait pas dans la
ligne acceptable et qui ferait émerger
une réflexion autre. Donc je pense que
là ça devient profondément dangereux
pour le pour la démocratie. Le décodex,
le décodex fait partie de ces
comment dire de ces pratiques
journalistiques qui et de ces ces
instances qui s'arrogent le droit de
décider ce qui est euh comment dire ce
qui est vrai et ce qui ne l'est pas, ce
qui est valable intellectuellement et ce
qui ne l'est pas. C'estàd que comment
vous dire quand il s'agit tout
simplement de déterminer si un fait est
euh réel ou pas, ça semble assez simple.
Voyez, si je vous dis euh une poule a
traversé et s'est fait écraser par un
train sur un passage à niveau, nous
pouvons vérifier que cette poule s'est
faite écraser par le passage au passage
à niveau par un train qui passait par
là. Donc si je dis non, ça n'est pas
arrivé, c'est une fake news si le la
poule effectivement s'est faite écraser.
En revanche, si on commence
à essayer déjà de d'expliquer ce qui
s'est réellement passé, là déjà ça
devient plus compliqué. Il n'y a plus
les faits, il y a l'explication, puis
ensuite il y a les responsabilités.
Est-ce que c'était de la faute de la
poule ou est-ce que c'était de la faute
du passage à niveau qui ne fonctionnait
pas ? Là, il peut y avoir enquête. Donc,
on attend l'enquête avant de donner
l'information. Mais si on commence
ensuite à déterminer s'il y a un je ne
sais pas moi une un système euh comment
dire économique et politique qui a
poussé cette poule à aller sur le
passage à niveau, là on entre dans
l'idéologie et là où est la vérité et où
est où est la la fake news ? il va y
avoir des analyses contradictoires et ça
s'appelle la politique. Dans la
politique, il n'y a pas forcément le
vrai et le faux parce qu'il n'y a pas
forcément les faits et ce qui ne relève
pas des faits. Il y a des idéologies
contradictoires. Quand on me dit par
exemple
écoutez, nous allons faire la monnaie
unique et ça va apporter la prospérité
en Europe, la croissance, la fin du
chômage de masse. C'était une fake news,
non ?
Pourtant, ça a permis de faire passer le
traité de Mastrift et ça a permis
d'imposer en Europe le l'euro tel qu'il
est. Bon, donc les fake news, c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement relatif.
Encore une fois, tant qu'il tant qu'on
parle de fait, on peut déterminer si on
rentre sur la politique, on n'est plus
dans une question de fait. On est dans
une question de choix contradictoire. Et
la question est de déterminer au nom de
quel principe et de quelle valeur on met
en avant ces choix. Donc là-dedans, le
décodex, à quoi il sert ? Et bien, il
sert à décider qui a droit à la parole
et qui ne l'a pas. C'estàd qui pense
bien et qui pense mal. Donc, ce sont des
journalistes qui s'arrogent le droit de
juger les autres journalistes, d'être à
la fois jugé parti et de dire que telle
idée est juste ou n'est pas juste parce
que dans leur façon dont il fonctionne,
il juge de la validité d'un site dans
son ensemble et pas seulement d'un fait
ponctuel qui serait traité sur tel site.
Donc, on va décider que tel site mal et
donc
paramalgame,
pardon,
par amalgame.
Oui, par amalgame. et puis surtout par
idéologie pure par euh parce que ce sont
parfois des gens qui posent les
mauvaises questions, qui traitent les
sujets dont il ne faut pas parler et
c'estquel qu'il faut pas parler ? Ça
peut être par exemple toutes ces
questions économiques dont j'évoquais le
l'étendu, que ce soit la question du
protectionnisme et du libre échange, que
ce soit la question géopolitique, voilà,
les flux migratoires, que ce soit la
question géopolitique de rapport entre
les États-Unis, la Russie, le la façon
dont on va dont on va lire les rapports
de force, est-ce qu'on estime que la
Russie est forcément un grand méchant
face aux gentil États-Unis, est-ce que
on oublie, on occulte l'impérialisme
américain ou est-ce qu'on ne l'occulte
pas ? sur toutes ces questions là. Donc
il y a une façon de décider ce qui est
bien et ce qui est mal qui moi me
dérange profondément parce que j'estime
que il y a des lectures qui peuvent être
diverses et que par exemple la façon
dont on
dont on décrit ce qui s'est passé en
Ukraine, la façon dont on essaie de
penser ce qui se passe aujourd'hui entre
l'Iran, Israël, les États-Unis, et bien
c'est ce n'est pas à un site internet ou
à un groupe de journalistes si respecte
respectable soit-il de décider ce qu'il
convient de dire sur ces questionsl ou
pas. Je pense que ça s'appelle le débat
démocratique.
Le CSA dans tout ça,
[soupir]
le CSA est très occupé actuellement à
essayer de décider si quand un type la
jupe d'une jeune femme à la télévision,
c'est grave ou pas ? Je pense qu'il y a
des c'est vraiment il a des vrais sujets
de de préoccupation le CSA. Donc non, il
me semble que le CSA est une instance
qui ne fonctionne pas aujourd'hui comme
il devrait parce qu'il est devenu
essentiellement une boîte de réception
de l'indignation de
de gens actifs sur les réseaux sociaux
et que ce n'est peut-être pas comme ça
qu'on pourrait penser une instance de
régulation des médias qui devrait plutôt
réfléchir, je ne sais pas moi, à la
concentration par exemple de certains
médias dans les mains de quelques
propriétaires.
Je pense que là, il y aurait des
questions à se poser. Pour autant, il
n'appartient pas non plus au CSA de
déterminer ce qui relève d'une fake news
et ce qui n'en relève pas. Et là aussi,
le discours d'Emmanuel Macron lors de
ses vœux à la presse m'a profondément
inquiété quand il a commencé à évoquer
l'idée que le CSA devait être plus
impliqué dans la façon dont on allait
juger les le contenu des médias. Et il
me semble que on va vers une dérive euh
qui entend réguler ce le contenu de
de du travail euh journalistique et qui
entend surtout éviter toute pensée
pluraliste. Donc je pense que c'est pas
exactement l'idée que je me fais de la
démocratie.
Des préconisations pour tout ça ?
des préconisations, elles sont
euh elles sont tellement vastes en fait
dans la mesure où je pense qu'il y a un
une conjonction de facteurs qui
expliquent aujourd'hui le paysage
médiatique tel qu'il existe. facteurs
économiques, c'est-à-dire le la
concentration, l'hyperconcentration des
médias aujourd'hui dans dans quelques
mains et dans des mains qui sont celles
de
groupes industriels qui ont un poids
absolument démesuré,
facteur sociologique sur la façon dont
on recrute les journalistes et dont on
les forme dans la mesure où je pense que
les écoles de journalisme par exemple
sont joue un rôle qui n'est pas
forcément qui ne va pas dans le sens du
pluralisme et qui ne permet pas de
former des esprits libres. Et je pense
que le
on peut y ajouter un problème
spécifiquement français qui est le fait
que l'hypercentralisation de la France
fait que l'ensemble des médias nationaux
est regroupé à Paris. Ce qu'il a aussi
restreint totalement le champ de vision
des journalistes. C'est-à-dire que même
si des jeunes journalistes viennent de
province, ont vécu en province, le fait
d'être ensuite concentré à Paris dans un
univers qui est finalement assez réduit
les coupe parfois de toute une part de
ce qu'il devrait voir en tant que
journaliste, ce dont il devraient être
capable de parler et qui relève d'une
réalité qui du coup disparaît disparaît
du champ journalistique. Et ça, je pense
que c'est profondément dangereux.
on pourrait y ajouter une question de de
culture générale aussi de disons que je
pense que le
le recrutement de des journalistes
disons en s'appuyant uniquement sur les
écoles de journalisme restreint là aussi
totalement la diversité de pensées
qu'ils peuvent avoir. Voilà, c'est un
ensemble de facteurs. Il y a les
facteurs économiques, les facteurs
sociologiques, des facteurs politiques.
l'espèce de lien qui n'est toujours pas
rompu
le milieu journalistique et le milieu
politique avec une forme de j'allais
dire presque de fascination réciproque
et qui là aussi
comment dire incite les journalistes à
vouloir être reconnu par les milieux
politiques et pour être reconnus il faut
penser bien il faut penser comme doivent
penser les milieux politiques.
[raclement de gorge] Ce qui là aussi
restreint totalement la liberté, la
capacité à penser différemment. Donc je
pense que il faudrait pouvoir traiter
tous ces sujets-l en même temps, mais je
pense que c'est aussi par la diversité
des acteurs qu'on peut le faire et c'est
pour ça que l'idée qu'on va imposer des
labels qui vont réduire le nombre de
médias, notamment de médias alternatifs
me semble absolument ahurissant.
Question d'Internet : comment développer
l'esprit critique des lecteurs ? Bah euh
en lisant le l'esprit critique se
développe par la lecture, [grognement]
c'est-à-dire par la par la capacité à
à relier un fait euh avec d'autres
choses qui semblaient totalement
différentes. Euh intelligence vient de
interligérer, relier les choses entre
elles, donc faire le rapport entre les
choses. Ça nécessite d'avoir
suffisamment de culture historique, de
culture politique, de culture littéraire
aussi pour ne pas dépendre de la vision
du monde qui est contenue dans l'article
qu'on lit. C'est-à-dire être capable
justement de discerner ce qui relève
d'une vision du monde et ce qui relève
de simples fait. Donc il faut avoir
soi-même beaucoup lu pour pouvoir
prendre ce recul et être capable de se
forger sa propre sa sa propre opinion à
partir de ce qui est déversé par les
médias.
On va on va parler de
flux migratoire.
Comment vous informez sur le sujet ?
Quelles sont vos positions sur ce
sujet-là ? Comment vous voyez
l'évolution
de ce facteur là ? Écoutez, je pense que
[raclement de gorge]
c'est un sujet qui a été euh totalement
tostracisé par les médias pendant des
années. Il était impensable d'en parler.
Et je me souviens quand j'ai commencé
dans le journalisme, j'ai commencé à
Marianne donc où là aussi ce journal
était euh considéré comme un journal
provocateur voire dangereux parce que il
avait euh posé comme principe qu'on
pouvait parler de tout, même de ces
questions-là, même des questions de
sécurité, d'immigration, de voilà tout
ce genre de sujet. Et c'est moi j'y suis
arrivée donc au début des années 2000.
Et il semblait totalement scandaleux
d'aborder ces sujets-là parce que le
dogme voulait que si on abordait ces
questions-là, c'était déjà le premier
pas vers le racisme. Or, je pense que
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à un
bouleversement absolument majeur et que
se contenter là aussi de traiter ces
sujets-là en terme de bien et de mal est
absolument euh criminel. D'abord parce
que
la dimension profondément humaine de ces
questions-là nous oblige à essayer de
réfléchir en mêlant à la fois la
question humanitaire et la question
politique. Ensuite, parce que
il est nécessaire de sortir du piège qui
consiste
une fois de plus à être dans les
opposition binaire, c'est-à-dire d'un
côté ceux qui veulent une fermeture
absolue des frontières en expliquant que
de toute façon il y a eu trop
d'immigration qu'il faut arrêter et de
l'autre ceux qui vous expliquent que il
faudrait absolument accueillir
n'importe quelle personne qui se
présente dans un pays. Je crois
profondément au droits des pays à
décider qui vient sur leur sol parce que
c'est nécessaire pour maintenir une
communauté politique apaisée et une
communauté politique qui peut jouer son
rôle démocratique.
Donc pour que ce soit possible,
il est nécessaire d'abord
de distinguer
l'asile, le droit d'asile qui est qui
est un droit fondamental contre lequel
il ne faut surtout pas enfin qu'il ne
faut surtout pas mettre en danger
[grognement] et des migrations
économiques. Ensuite, sur ces migrations
économiques, nous avons un problème,
c'est que notre gouvernement peut dire
tout ce qu'il veut tant que les règles
européennes ne sont pas changées.
Il n'y a pas de souveraineté sur cette
questionlà. Donc nous ne ferons rien.
Par exemple, expliquer qu'il faut
reconduire à la frontière des des
migrants, mais on les reconduit à la
frontière italienne parce queils sont
rentrés en Union européenne en Italie.
Donc il reviennent aussitôt. Donc on
crée une espèce de flux absolument
ignoble de gens qui vont passer des
années à essayer de de revenir dans des
conditions épouvantables. Tout cela ne
sert à rien. Mais je pense surtout que
on ne peut pas traiter cette questionlà
si on ne traite pas en amont la question
de savoir pourquoi des gens quittent
leur pays. Nous allons avoir une d'abord
une bombe démographique puisque des pays
comme le Nigéria par exemple vont avoir
plus de enfin ont déjà plus de 50 % de
leur population qui a moins de 25 ans et
vont voir leur population doubler dans
les années qui viennent.
C'est une question économique,
c'est-à-dire que tant que l'Afrique sera
pillée de ses richesses par des
multinationales, il faudra pas s'étonner
de voir des gens poussés par la pauvreté
venir jusque chez nous. Donc il me
semble pour ma part que et d'ailleurs ça
c'est c'est ce qu'avait dit c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je crois il y a
quelques temps qui avait dit tout départ
est une souffrance.
C'est rare de voir un homme politique de
ce bord-là prononcer cette phrase-là.
Oui. Euh je crois profondément au droit
à vivre et à travailler au pays, que ce
soit sur le plan régional ou sur le plan
national. Et donc je pense que beaucoup
de gens seraient beaucoup plus heureux
s'ils n'étaient pas poussés à l'exil.
Donc si nous voulons éviter quelque
chose qui va déstabiliser profondément
l'Europe, c'est le système économique
qu'il faut modifier. C'est le pouvoir
des multinationales qui sont en train
regarder par exemple le cas de la boxite
euh où vous avez quelques
multinationales qui sont en train de
piller la Guinée Bissao en interdisant
euh en ne créant aucun emploi sur place
en en s'appropriant les tous les revenus
miniers. Euh je pense que tant que les
États européens soutiendront ce genre de
choses l'accepteront, il ne faudra pas
se plaindre de voir des des migrants
arriver en Europe. Or, je pense que
cette ces flux migratoires ne peuvent se
passer bien que s'ils ne sont pas trop
importants. Pourquoi ? Parce que tout
simplement encore une pour qu'il y pour
maintenir une démocratie, il faut une
communauté politique apaisée. Il faut
une forme d'intégration qui ne peut bien
se passer. que si il n'y a pas de
déséquilibre trop profond. Donc là
encore, on peut pas traiter ce sujet de
façon unilatérale. Il y a la dimension
économique, il y a la dimension
démographique, il y a la dimension
ensuite dans les pays d'accueil qui est
la dimension d'intégration, une
dimension culturelle. C'est-à-dire que
ça ne peut bien se passer que si vous
avez de la part des habitants du pays
d'accueil la certitude qu'ils ne seront
pas un jour minoritaires chez eux. Et
donc pour apaiser cette peur et bien il
faut intégrer, c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
expliquer, il faut garantir à ses
habitants que les nouveaux venus
ne se n'apporteront pas des valeurs
différentes, trop différentes de celles
du pays d'accueil. Donc ça c'est un
travail que nous nous devons mener mais
vous voyez qu' là encore on traite pas
les choses.
Est-ce que le voile est-ce que le voile
islamique du moins le voile pour les
musulmans, c'est une valeur qui ne qui a
été apportée et qui ne fait pas partie
de la France à vos yeux. Est-ce que
c'est ça ou est-ce que ça peut être
considéré comme ça ?
C'est pas une question de pas faire
partie de la France. On peut pas le dire
en ces termes-là. C'est pas ça, c'est
que pour ma part, je demande le droit de
dire que un signe
à la fois religieux et politique qui
matérialise
le fait que la femme est responsable du
désir qu'elle fait naître me pose
problème. Ça ne signifie pas que je veux
l'interdire dans l'espace public. Je
pense que ça fait partie des choses qui
relèvent de la liberté individuelle.
Mais pour autant, dans la façon dont la
France a construit le rapport entre les
hommes et les femmes, c'est en
contradiction absolu avec cette ce
rapport homme-femme, avec cette façon
d'organiser les l'espace public. Donc
c'est compliqué euh tant que c'est un
disons tant que tant que ça reste un
signe religieux,
il a tout à fait droit de citer dans
l'espace public puisqu'on peut
évidemment afficher des signes religieux
dans l'espace public sans aucun
problème. Le problème est quand il
devient un marqueur identitaire qui
consiste à afficher son refus des
valeurs dominantes de la société. Alors
évidemment, plus il y a crispation dans
un sens et plus qu'il y a crispation
dans l'autre. C'estàdire que si on se
focalise totalement sur le voile, on
provoque une réaction qui est une
réaction en retour et en effet une
affirmation identitaire avec ce voile.
Donc je pense qu'il faudrait apaiser les
choses et ne pas par exemple hystériser
le débat à chaque fois que on voit une
jeune femme voilée par exemple dans un
télécrochet comme
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par voiler ?
comme The Voice avec le turban, il y a
le hijab qui cache les oreilles c'est ce
que j'allais dire. Il y a toutes les
formes de voile. C'estàd que la cette
chanteuse Menel qui a provoqué un
comment dire des réactions
hypertrophiées sur les réseaux sociaux
portait tout simplement une forme de
turban qui cachait ses elle enflammé
parce qu'elle avait fait des tweets des
tweets de jeunesse comme ils appellent
ça.
Oui. Et ça ça c'est c'était c'est un
autre problème en fait. Et il y en
[grognement] a clairement qui n'ont pas
supporté de voir une jeune femme qui
cachait ses cheveux à la télévision. Or,
je pense que elle est libre de le faire.
Je je suis pour l'interdiction des
signes religieux à l'école parce que
l'école est un espace spécifique et que
de toute façon il existait une
circulaire qui datait de Jean Zet
ministre de du Front populaire qui
interdisait les signes religieux à
l'école et les signes politiques. Bon,
il aurait suffi en 89 lors des premières
affaires de voile de rappeler que cette
circulaire était toujours en vigueur et
il y avait pas de problème. Hélas, ça
n'a pas été fait par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale de l'époque,
Lionel Jospin.
hors de cet espace spécifique qui école,
on est libre d'afficher des signes
religieux. En revanche, il y a en effet
toutes les formes de voile. C'est-à-dire
que ça n'est pas le même euh comment
dire le même message adressé à la
société que de porter un foulard qui
cache les cheveux ou de cacher
l'ensemble du coup ou même de porter une
abaaya sombre qui masque absolument tout
le corps.
La bourka
Bourka c'est la bourka c'est pas ça. La
bourka c'est le le vêtement grillagé
d'Afghanistan.
Donc justement c'est tout tout cela est
différent. Euh en revanche, ce qu'on
appelle le nikab par exemple, toutes les
tous les vêtements euh l'ensemble des
vêtements noirs qui sont clairement euh
la marque d'un islamisme politisé et qui
sont un qui relèvent d'un message
politique euh me pose profondément
problème, d'autant que c'est un c'est
une c'est en fait un refus de l'espace
social commun qui est affiché par là. Et
donc je crois que c'est c'est en cela
que c'est dangereux, c'est-à-dire que ça
relève d'un séparatisme social. C'est
compréhensible quand on voit Bimbo Enco
dans les téléréalités
habillé
on va dire plus que légèrement. Est-ce
que c'est pas compréhensible
de rebasculer vers des des valeurs plus
identitaires et plus refermées sur soi ?
Alors, je pense qu'on peut refuser le
consumérisme et l'instrumentalisation du
corps de la femme sans pour autant rêver
de l'enfermer en considérant qu'elle est
euh responsable de du désir et que il
faut cacher son corps. Je j'ose espérer
qu'il y a un juste milieu entre les
deux. C'est-à-dire que pour ma part, je
suis pas particulièrement adepte des des
clips de MTV et des de la de la façon
totalement effarante et dégradante dont
sont présentés. les femmes dans certains
dans certains clips.
Pour autant, ça ne m'oblige pas à prener
une pudeur dont seule la femme serait la
victime. Voilà. Et je ne pense pas que
les femmes qui ne se cachent pas les
cheveux sont impudiques. Or, voyez, ça
c'est une conception des choses qui
relèvent de rapports hommes-femmes qui
ne sont pas ceux que nous avons
développé en France. Alors, en plus sur
la question des rapports hommes-femmes,
le vraiment la France a une place assez
spécifique et c'est ça d'ailleurs qui
fait sans doute que nous avons ce
rapport un peu complexe non seulement au
voile mais à la question féministe,
c'est que nous ne sommes n
l'espèce de comment dire de culture
méditerranéenne au sens large où la la
femme est plutôt dévouée à l'espace
privé pendant que l'homme est dans
l'espace public, ce qui existe depuis la
Grèce antique. avec le principe du Gessé
jusqu'à aujourd'hui dans certains pays
du pourtour méditerranéen. Mais nous ne
sommes pas non plus dans cette autre
forme de séparatisme qu'on pu développer
des sociétés anglo-saxones où finalement
même si les femmes participent à
l'espace public, hommes et femmes vivent
plutôt séparés et
du coup on a pu développer des formes de
féminisme qui sont des qui qui relèvent
de la j'allais dire presque de la guerre
des sexes. Nous en France, nous sommes
les héritiers d'une tradition un peu
complexe qui relève à la fois de l'amour
courtois et de la galanterie.
Ça ne ça n'empêche pas le machisme, ça
n'empêche pas la domination masculine.
Mais ça la va dire que c'est une façon
de gérer le problème un peu différente
qui essaie de penser le rapport
homme-femme par un dépassement du désir
par le langage qui permet une mixité
dans l'espace public, qui permet aux
hommes et aux femmes de vivre ensemble.
Je serais profondément attristée que
cette façon très particulière de
permettre la mixité disparaisse
soit au profit du le de l'enfermement
des femmes, quel qu'il soit sous un
voile ou dans une maison, soit au profit
d'un séparatisme qui empêcherait les
hommes et les femmes de vivre
tranquillement des relations qui parfois
sont des relations de désir. C'estàd que
je ne me satisfais pas du de certaines
formes du féminisme actuel, mais je me
satisfais encore moins évidemment de
cette idée que la femme ne serait
pudique que quand elle est enfermée sous
une bâche.
Pas mal. [soupir][raclement de gorge]
Oui, mais bon, je pense là ce que là
encore la nuance est devenue très
compliquée à à défendre. Qui a un
macartisme au niveau de des opinions, on
peut plus débattre, on peut plus euh
échanger euh sereinement en France.
Non, c'est vrai et tout le monde le
sent. C'est-à-dire que il y a une
radicalisation
des des opinions qui me semblent
profondément dangereuses et une
incapacité à accepter le débat
politique. C'est-à-dire que nous sommes
dans un une nouvelle forme de retour du
religieux dans le sens où les problèmes
ne sont plus pensés en terme politique,
c'est-à-dire des options et des choix
différents dont il faut débattre pour
trouver un compromis. Mais en terme de
bien et de mal, c'est-à-dire le fait que
l'autre est forcément dans le camp du
mal et qu'il faut soit l'éradiquer comme
un hérétique, soit le rééduquer. Or, de
plus en plus, les débats sont posés en
ces termes-là et on le voit notamment
sur toutes les questions sociétales.
La question du féminisme en est une,
mais il y en a énormément d'autres où
finalement
on perçoit qu'il est devenu totalement
impensable de ne de remettre en cause le
dogme voulu au nom de notre bien à tous.
En fait, ce qui me dérange là-dedans,
c'est une fois de plus, on en revient
toujours là à la question démocratique.
C'est-à-dire que je perçois ça comme une
infantilisation totale des individus.
C'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit de leur
expliquer comment ils doivent penser
plutôt que de leur donner les moyens de
choisir par eux-mêmes ce qu'ils voudront
penser. Un exemple simple, celui du vin.
Je j'ai consacré là ma dernière tribune,
ma dernière chronique dans le dans le
Figaro. Nous, notre vin quotidien, c'est
ça.
Voilà cette question du vin euh parce
que pour une fois, j'ai trouvé que
Emmanuel Macron avait prononcé une
phrase qui me semblait importante et
essentielle. Elle est parfaitement
tanodine mais elle est très symbolique
puisqu'il a expliqué
que lui buvait du vin midi et soir. Donc
il aurait dû dire au repas de midi et au
repas du soir parce que c'est c'est ça
le l'idée, c'est que le vin est une
boisson de table. Et il répondait en
cela à sa propre ministre de la santé
qui expliquait que l'industrie du vin
essae d'imposer l'idée que le vin serait
spécifique. C'est pas vrai. C'est ce
tous les alcools se valent. ils sont
dangereux et cetera. Ce qui est une
façon selon moi profondément
infantilisante de traiter la question de
l'alcoolisme. Personne ne va ni qu'il y
a de l'alcoolisme que ça provoque une
souffrance et des maladies terribles.
Pour autant, il me semble que les
citoyens majeurs sont adultes, qu'ils
sont capables de choisir leurs actes, de
décider quel risque ils veulent prendre,
quel risque ils ne veulent pas prendre,
jusqu'où ils peuvent aller. Donc il faut
les informer, il faut leur expliquer le
danger des molécules d'alcool, la façon
dont ça se passe dans le corps, ça oui.
Mais leur expliquer que quoi qu'il
arrive, le premier verre de vin va les
conduire au cancer et que tous les
alcools se valent parce que le vin
serait un alcool. Là, ça me semble une
façon quasi religieuse de prendre les
choses. Le vin est une boisson de table
qui contient de l'alcool. C'est pas un
alcool. C'est on ne le boit pas en
général pour l'alcool qu'il contient
mais pour le goût qu'il a et la culture
qu'il porte. qu'il y en ait qui se
saoulent au vin, qui soient des
alcooliques au vin, ça existe. Mais ce
n'est pas parce qu'il y a une déviance
qu'il faut priver l'ensemble de la
population de quelque chose qui qui
relève d'un patrimoine, d'un mode de vie
et d'une façon d'être au monde qui qui
sont essentiels dans la culture, dans la
dans la civilisation très spécifique
qu'a créé la France. Et je remarque
d'ailleurs que les gens qui en général
sont les plus farouches euh pour
expliquer aux Français qu'ils ne doivent
surtout pas boire un verre de vin et que
c'est très néfaste et cetera, sont en
général des gens qui estiment que pour
eux-mêmes en revanche, ils peuvent boire
des bonnes bouteilles entre amis parce
que eux ils savent mais que les autres
sont des abrutis qui ne savent pas. Donc
ça ça me dérange. Je pense que la le
travail démocratique sur ce sujet-là qui
peut sembler anecdotique comme sur tous
les autres, c'est de faire en sorte que
chaque individu puisse opérer ses choix,
qu'il ne soit pasé par un système. Or,
nous sommes dans un système qui au
contraire s'appuie sur l'aliénation.
C'est-à-dire que nous sommes dans un
système économique fondé sur la
consommation de masse, donc qui essa de
manipuler les pulsions des individus, de
d'hyiler leurs raisons pour qu'ils
achètent et qu'ils soient des éléments
de la machine économique. Donc nous
sommes dans le système le plus aliénant
possible. Donc au contraire, je
préférerais que nous sortions, que nous
nous émancipions de ce système
consumériste et que chacun à travers des
informations
qu'il aura acquise par le travail des
médias puisse décider pour lui-même de
la façon dont il veut mener sa vie.
Trop tard, c'est pas trop tard après des
décennies d'infantilisation
avec une élite qui il y a eu un papier
de tod récemment sur la chrétinisation
des élites.
C'est pas trop tard. On n pas une masse
inercielle de de je vais je vais parler
trivialement mais de gros boulets qui
ont été bercés au biberon de la douce
nouvelle pendant des décennies. Est-ce
qu'on c'est pas un peu trop tard pour se
s'emparer de son esprit critique de
comment fonctionne le système de contrer
les idéologies qu'on nous soumet de A à
Z ? L'idéologie dominante ? C'est pas un
peu trop tard ? Si on considère qu'il
est trop tard, on peut
retourner cultiver son jardin,
construire un falanster et y vivre
heureux. Et je pense que ce serait un
bonheur absolu d'aller en effet cultiver
son jardin.
Mais pour ma part, il se trouve que j'ai
j'ai des enfants et que je considère que
je suis responsable du monde dans lequel
je les ai mis.
Donc pour l'instant, j'essaie euh non
seulement de me dire qu'il n'est pas
trop tard,
mais j'essaie de faire en sorte d'avoir
apporté ma part,
d'avoir essayé un tout petit peu
d'améliorer ce monde qui, en effet ne me
convient pas tel qu'il est. C'estàd que
la question n'est pas qu'il soit trop
tard ou trop tôt. Je ne me pose jamais
la question de savoir si c'était mieux
avant, si ce sera mieux après. C'est pas
mon problème. Je ne suis ni optimiste ni
pessimiste parce que ça relève de la
foi. L'optimisme ou le pessimisme. Oh,
je crois que les choses vont aller mieux
ou je crois qu'elles vont aller moins
bien. Moi, je ne suis pas dans la foi,
je suis dans la pensée politique et
l'action. C'estàd que j'essaie de faire
en sorte que le monde ressemble à disons
ce que ce qu'il devrait être. Si nous
étions dans une véritable démocratie, si
les individus étaient émancipés. Donc
voilà, j'essaie de m'en donner les
moyens. Le jour où je m'apercevrai que
décidément je ne sers à rien, en effet,
j'irais cultiver mon jardin avec le plus
grand des bonheurs.
Alors, comment comment penser le monde
comme il devrait être ? C'est ça. On va
déjà commencer par penser la France.
Comment la France devrait être ?
[grognement]
Comment la France devrait être vaste
programme ? Bien, elle
je pense déjà et je je reviens toujours
là qu'elle devrait être une démocratie,
c'est-à-dire que il faudrait articuler
la souveraineté du peuple, c'est la
capacité pour le peuple de décider de
son destin avec la souveraineté de la
nation parce qu'il n'y a pas de
souveraineté du peuple quand une nation
est dominée et que du coup les choix du
peuple ne sont pas entendus parce qu'il
y a quelque chose qui prévaut et avec la
souveraineté des individus, c'est-à-dire
la capacité pour chacun d'exercer son
libre arbitre. C'est ça la démocratie.
Or, c'est de l'Europe qui fait quoi ?
Disons que euh au moins on introduit un
rapport de force suffisamment brutal
pour euh aller jusqu'au bout des
tentatives pour changer les choses.
C'est-à-dire que j'estime que euh
quand je parle d'un rapport de force
brutal, euh je pense que si on part du
principe qu'on ne sortira pas de
l'Europe, il n'y a plus de rapport de
force. Donc il faut partir du principe,
c'est le principe, c'est comme la
disuasion nucléaire, il faut partir du
principe qu'on pourrait en sortir. Déjà
là, on a les moyens de peser un petit
peu plus que quand on dit "Mais ne vous
inquiétez pas, nous nous ne changerons
pas les règles du jeu." Ne vous
inquiétez pas. On voudrait bien par
exemple que on révise la directrice
travailleur détaché. On voudrait bien
bon être un peu plus indépendant des
États-Unis en terme de défense mais mais
vous inquiétez pas, on touche pas les
règles du jeu et on se conformera à une
fin. Bon voilà, c'est on sait très bien
que c'est mort. Donc la question c'est
de savoir comment on introduit ce
rapport de force en étant prêt à aller
jusqu'au bout. Ce qui veut pas dire
qu'on souhaite aller jusqu'au bout,
c'est pas le problème. Mais en tout cas,
on y est prêt parce que on décide qu'il
y a quelque chose qui vaut par-dessus
tout. C'est la possibilité pour le
peuple de décider de son destin que sans
cela nous ne sommes plus en démocratie.
Nous sommes dans un système qui est
oligarchique à tendance totalitaire.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les flux de
migrants ?
migrants ? Mais c'est la même chose de
toute façon. Ça ça doit se régler en
partie pour l'instant au niveau
européen.
Le mur le mur on le construit où ? En
Italie, en Espagne ? On fait pas de mur
? On ne construit pas de murs parce que
les murs ça ne marche pas. De toute
façon, il y a déjà un mur qui s'appelle
la mer Méditerranée et on voit ce que ça
donne avec des malheureux qui y crèvent.
Donc la question n'est pas là. La
question est de savoir comment on
organise
directement dans les pays de départ déjà
la possibilité pour certains de demander
l'asile, comment on fait en sorte que
des on n'est pas des malheureux qui
crèvent de faim qui donc éprouvent le
besoin de venir et de et de prendre des
risques absolument monstrueux. Et là, il
e fallu ne pas détruire la Libye, ça
aurait peut-être été pas mal aussi pour
éviter
il fallait couvrir de trois bagouilles.
Ben voilà, mais je pense que là la
responsabilité
de ceux qui ont décidé
avec nos impôts
de faire en sorte que la Libye soit dans
l'état où elle est aujourd'hui, c'est
une responsabilité terrible. Parce que
quand on voit la façon dont sont traités
les migrants qui passent par la Libye,
euh les forces armées françaises
estiment après avoir interrogé donc tous
les les migrants qui passent que une
femme qui passe par là a en moyenne été
violée h fois. Voilà. Euh, il y a des
hommes qui sont réduits en esclavage,
qui sont torturés. Bon, ça je le porter
comme responsabilité.
Est-ce que Est-ce que les Français
doivent porter cette responsabilité ou
est-ce que les Français doivent trouver
des coupables ?
Ils doivent avoir conscience que il y a
une responsabilité
collective.
collective puisque globalement, si je me
souviens bien, il y a quand même
beaucoup de monde qui a applaudi à cette
à cette action en Libye.
Je pense que donc il s'agit pas de se de
faire de la repentance facile, il s'agit
d'en tirer des conclusions sur ce qu'on
va faire maintenant, c'est-à-dire éviter
de de répéter les mêmes erreurs,
c'est-à-dire arrêter de concevoir le
monde en terme de bien et de mal avec
les gentils et les méchants et essayer
de comprendre comment on peut à la fois
apporter de la stabilité dans les
différents pays
qui sont à la qui sont les pays
de passage des flux migratoires et les
pays de départ des flux migratoires.
Comment on fait pour ne pas cautionner
le pillage des matières premières ?
Comment on fait pour permettre le
développement réel de ces pays-là par
une agriculture vivrière, par une
reprise en main de leur
de toute leur leur richesse ? Comment on
fait pour ne pas cautionner des pouvoirs
qui sont des pouvoirs qui écrasent leur
peuple et qui les volent ? Oui, c'est un
très vaste programme mais je pense que
c'est la seule réponse actuelle au flux
migratoire parce que si on se contente
de regarder ce qui se passe en en
Europe, on est pris entre le donc la
l'obligation humanitaire, c'estàd de pas
laisser crever des gens et le risque de
déstabilisation profonde de nos propres
sociétés. Donc on va à la catastrophe.
On fait quoi avec les États-Unis ? On se
positionne comment dans la France rêvée
de de Natacha ? [rires]
Je pense que
dans un sens euh
Donald Trump est en partie notre plus
grande chance parce que il faut se dire
que si il n'avait pas été élu,
nous serions encore plus dépendants des
États-Unis. C'est-à-dire que nous
aurions des élites qui continueraient à
estimer que les États-Unis sont le bien
absolu et qu'il faut euh surtout
s'abstenir de tout esprit critique
vis-à-vis de leur choix. Au moins là,
Donald Trump agit comme un repoussoir et
donc impose que on commence à se poser
la question par exemple d'une défense
européenne, par exemple d'une forme
d'indépendance, de souveraineté.
C'est déjà pas mal. On on est très très
loin de de quoi que ce soit qui puisse
ressembler à une véritable indépendance.
Pour l'instant euh sur les questions
numériques, nous sommes une colonie
américaine.
Euh sur les questions de défense aussi,
c'estàd que dans la mesure où nous
n'avons pas le droit de vendre des
armements par exemple qui contiennent un
composant américain sans demander
l'autorisation des États-Unis, mais là
on le voit avec la dernière vente de
rafale à l'Égypte, les États-Unis
peuvent décider de dire non. Tout ça
parce qu'il y a une micropuce dans les
rafales qui est fabriquée aux
États-Unis.
On va voir ça aussi avec la façon dont
Donald Trump va petit à petit, enfin il
a commencé à essayer d'imposer euh aux
entreprises européennes de cesser
tous leurs investissements en Iran. Donc
est-ce que nous serons capables de
résister à ça ou est-ce que nous allons
nous coucher et accepter le
cette forme d'impérialisme
doublé de l'extraterritorialité du droit
américain qui fait que et bien euh nous
nos entreprises sont menacées de
d'amendees absolument énormes quand
elles commerce avec un pays qui est
blacklisté par les États-Unis. Est-ce
qu'on va accepter ça ou pas ? C'est tout
ça qui va se jouer. Mais nous ne pouvons
pas prétendre avoir aujourd'hui une
politique indépendante si nous
continuons à accepter l'ensemble de ces
données là. Or, pour l'instant, il y a
dans l'Union européenne des pays à qui
ça convient très bien et qui donc vont
empêcher toute indépendance véritable.
Euh je pense à la Pologne, mais bon,
même les les Allemands jouent un rôle
très ambivalent sur ces questions-là.
Donc comment on fait pour imposer cette
souveraineté et cette indépendance ?
Comment on fait pour petit à petit
réformer totalement ? Il faut un comment
dire une volonté politique euh
absolument énorme qui visiblement pour
l'instant n'est pas encore là.
Avec la Russie, on a on entretient quoi
comme rapport ? On fait quoi avec eux ?
On entretient les mêmes rapports qu'avec
d'autres pays. C'est-à-dire c'est pas
parce qu'on ne les trouve pas à notre
goût qu'on ne leur parle pas.
Euh le la géopolitique ce n'est pas
d'aller parler aux gens qu'on trouve
gentils et sympathiques. Donc là, en
l'occurrence la Russie est un pays qui
euh qui développe
ses enfin qui protège ses intérêts et
qui développe une forme de
d'indépendance.
Notre rôle n'est pas de juger si c'est
bien ou si c'est mal, mais de savoir
comment nous pouvons nous éviter de
dépendre soit de la Russie, soit de la
Chine, soit de des États-Unis. Donc par
exemple en terme énergétique, est-ce que
nous sommes capables euh de ne pas nous
retrouver pris au piège entre le gaz
russe et la volonté des États-Unis de
euh de comment dire de d'empêcher cette
relation commerciale. Voilà toute la
question. Donc là aussi ça le problème
c'est que nous sommes dans des dans une
comment dire euh dans un processus
européen qui nous interdit de penser ces
choses-là. C'estàd que le l'Europe à 27
est faite pour éviter cette réflexionlà.
Elle est faite pour construire une
dépendance vis-à-vis des États-Unis et
donc pour entrer dans ce processus de
guerre froide qui est mis en place par
les États-Unis depuis euh depuis
quelques années. Donc
là, le problème c'est que les relations
vont certainement se tendre. C'estàd
qu'il y a autour de Donald Trump des
gens qui visiblement veulent la guerre,
une forme de guerre. Euh que ce soit en
Syrie, en Ukraine, en Corée du Nord, il
y a tout un clan qui pousse à la guerre
et qui tient Donald Trump euh pour sur
ses affaires russes qui donc fait en
sorte que en gros il se couche.
Euh où se situeront les pays européens
en cas d'affrontement ? Il y a eu par
exemple là le 7 février
en Syrie un événement dont les médias
français ont non on pas parler à ma
connaissance ou quasiment pas.
des mercenaires russes se sont fait
bombarder par
l'aviation américaine. Officiellement
cinq morts en fait peut-être entre 100
200 morts. Ce sont des mercenaires,
c'est pas l'armée russe mais il y a en
Syrie une comment dire une confrontation
entre les Russes et les Américains qui
peut déraper tout moment.
Où nous situons-nous à ce moment-là ?
C'est ça la question. Qu'est-ce que nous
allons faire ? On aime bien être entre
le marteau et l'enclume.
Oui, c'est c'est pas la position la plus
agréable et je tiens pas du tout à y
être.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec Bacha ?
Mais c'est pareil, on évite de de
prendre nos rêves pour des réalités et
de croire que on peut décider que parce
que ce type est une ordure, il va
disparaître par miracle.
Donc je crois que on a pendant trop
longtemps eu une lecture totalement
maniquaine des choses.
Euh Bachar Elassad est une pourriture
qui n'hésite pas à massacrer son propre
peuple mais pour l'instant en face il y
a pas tellement de gens plus
recommandables. Et la question c'est de
savoir comment on stoppe le massacre et
comment on fait en sorte petit à petit
de rétablir une paix qui va permettre un
processus politique. Ce que ce que les
médias appellent comme massacre, est-ce
que on peut le requalifier comme dommage
collatéral ?
Ce terme de dommage collatéral me gêne
profondément dans la mesure où un être
humain n'est jamais un dommage
collatéral. En revanche, il faut avoir
conscience que euh dans toutes les
guerres, il y a des
voilà en terme militaire, il y a des
massacre et que en matière de dommage
collatéral lors des guerres sur les
nous avons vu en Europe en 1945 ce que
ça pouvait donner. à l'époque, on
n'hésitait pas à raser une ville de
200000 habitants euh comme dommage
collatéral ou pour faire avancer une
cause. Donc je pense que voilà, il faut
avoir conscience que la guerre est une
horreur, mais que c'est par des par un
travail géopolitique qu'on va pouvoir
agir et non pas par des grandes
déclarations sur le fait que tout ça est
très triste, très mal et que il faut
chasser Bachar Al-Assad. Là par exemple,
je vois le traitement médiatique sur
l'enclave de la Gouta. D'abord, c'est
intéressant ce terme d'enclave rebelle.
Voilà le qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
rebelle ? Qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière ?
On nous a déjà fait le coup avec Alep
Est euh donc on nous expliquait, on
avait toutes les images qui montraient
les horreurs commises par l'armée de
Bachar Al-Assad. Euh mais il y avait
rien pour euh il y avait il y avait pas
le moindre reportage dans Alep Est. Il a
fallu un temps fou pour que quelques
journalistes s'intéressent à ce qui se
passait réellement et à la façon dont la
population
avait été prise en otage par des groupes
djihadistes qui se comportaient de façon
absolument cauchemardesque. Donc je
pense que la le traitement de
l'information devrait être un tout petit
peu plus prudent sur ces questionsl ou
en tout cas il devrait éviter là aussi
de d'essayer de construire des des camps
en noir et en blanc. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec Israël ?
Là aussi, c'est une question euh comment
dire qui va de toute façon se poser de
toute façon parce que la politique menée
par Benjamin Netaniaahu est là euh
profondément dangereuse je pense et je
suis très attristée de voir à quel point
aujourd'hui en France il n'y a plus de
voix pour porter la critique de j'allais
dire de de voix d'intellectuels juifs
par exemple pour porter la critique
profonde réelle de la politique menée
par Benjamin desaniaou. On pouvait avoir
ça dans les années 90 2000. Il y avait
en France un débat sur ces questions là.
On se souvient de au moment de la la
deuxième tifada, il y avait eu des
prises de position extrêmement
courageuse, contradictoire.
Là, il y a plus rien, il y a plus de
discussion et l'État d'Israël va se
retrouver confronté à un problème
absolument majeur étant donné la la
politique menée depuis quelques années
par Netaniaou, c'est que [soupir]
là, Netaniau a fait en sorte que la
solution à deux états soit de moins en
moins possible avec les Palestiniens. Et
il se certains se mettent même à penser
ouvertement que et bien il va falloir un
seul état. Mais un seul état ça veut
dire quoi ? Un seul état démocratique
réellement ? Parce que le fondement
d'Israël
au départ c'était d'être un état
démocratique et juif.
là avec Israélistan
une sorte de il y avait ce rêve que ce
soit donc un état juif mais profondément
avec des avec un idéal qui au départ
d'ailleurs le sionisme c'était un idéal
de gauche he au départ et sauf que
aujourd'hui
si on détruit la solution à deux états,
si on ne fait qu'un seul état en
incluant donc les territoires
palestiniens,
c'est étant donné la démographie
Il va falloir à un moment donné choisir
entre état juif ou état démocratique.
Et là, ça va poser problème. Et je
crains que Israël petit à petit ne soit
confronté à cette question démocratique
de façon majeure. Donc, je pense que
cette cette politique là est
profondément dangereuse.
Je pense que la poursuite de la
colonisation à outrance est est un
facteur de déstabilisation
majeur en plus d'être une d'être un
scandale. [grognement]
Ils ont été condamnés. Non.
Ah oui, bah ça oui oui oui, il y a eu
des condamnations en effet à l'ONU et
c'est très très utile les condamnations
à l'ONU. Ça marche bien.
Non, je pense que là aussi c'est une
question de de géopolitique et de
rapport de force.
Est-ce que ça marche aussi bien que des
minutes de silence ? Oui, aussi bien que
des minutes de silence. C'est exactement
ça. Et des marches blanches aussi. On
peut aussi organiser des marches
blanches. Donc je pense que voilà la le
la question c'est une fois de plus c'est
en terme géopolitique qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? C'estàdire que l'axe là qui s'est
construit entre Donald Trump, Benamin
Benjamin Netaniaahu et euh le prince Ben
Salman de d'Arabie Saoudite euh est en
train de de déstabiliser euh le
Moyen-Orient s'il enfin si tent qu'il
ait jamais été stable. Mais là, en
l'occurrence euh on voit comment cela
provoque une montée des tensions euh
avec en ligne de mire l'Iran. Euh et ça
me semble euh comment dire
cous fil blanc.
Oui. Et je pense que le une fois de plus
le rôle des pays européens serait
d'essayer d'introduire,
on va dire, de la
au moins de la dissonance dans cette
dans cette jolie mélodie. le Qatar, on
continue de leur vendre des armes, on
continue de leur déplier le tapis rouge,
on fait quoi ? On leur dit "Bon
maintenant, ça suffit, on leur dit quoi
?"
B c'estàd que on a un problème, ils ont
l'argent, on l'a pas. Et
quand on quand on n pas de capitaux, on
va chercher les capitaux là où ils sont.
Et c'est le problème que rencontre la
France depuis 15 ans. C'estàd que nous
avons vendu, nous nous sommes vendus au
Qatar et à l'Arabie Saoudite parce que
nous n'avions plus de capitaux et que
nous avions besoin d'investissement.
Donc, il est nécessaire aussi de
reconstruire un tissu industriel, de
reconstruire des investissements, de
retrouver des capitaux propres, de
retrouver une indépendance économique
pour pouvoir se passer de ces alliés qui
n'en sont pas. C'est ça l'un sans
l'autre, ça ne marche pas.
Avec la France-Afrique, on arrête, on
continue. Le France CFA, on arrête, on
continue. On fait quoi avec tout ça ?
C'est la France Afrique, je l'ai évoqué
en creux en parlant de des problèmes
migratoires. C'est-à-dire que alors le
problème de la France-afrique, c'est
qu'elle existe plus sous la même forme.
C'està-dire que ce n'est pas l'État
français qui manipule, mais nous avons
des multinationales qui aujourd'hui
jouent un rôle dans les pays d'Afrique.
On a aussi des habitudes de
consommation.
Oui.
Qui poussent des multinationales.
On fait quoi ? Il faut changer nos
habitudes de consommation.
Bien sûr. C'est-à-dire que c'est là
qu'intervient la responsabilité des
individus. C'est-à-dire que nous sommes
dans un système économique
qui euh nous permet de dormir sur nos
deux oreilles en délocalisant notre
pollution dans des pays d'Asie et
d'Afrique, en ne regardant pas d'où
viennent les produits que nous utilisons
et en estimant que nous sommes des gens
bien parce que chez nous, c'est plutôt
apaisé et sympathique. Et en fait, c'est
notre consommation qui
qui provoque en Asie, en Afrique des
massacres, de la pauvreté, de la
pollution. Donc ce système- là n'est pas
tenable à terme. C'est-à-dire que nous
allons même en terme purement de
d'intérêt
égoïste, nous allons en payer les
conséquences. Nous le payons par les
flux migratoires et ça ça ne va faire
que s'amplifier. Donc, il va falloir en
effet revoir notre mode de consommation,
c'est-à-dire arrêter de bah de vivre à
crédit sur le reste de la planète. Ça ne
peut pas marcher plus longtemps. Donc,
il faut petit à petit relocaliser
l'économie, recréer des bassins
économiques avec une vie locale, des
produits qui ne traversent pas
l'ensemble de la planète en polluant
totalement. Mais ça ça ne peut se faire
que là aussi par un croisement entre la
volonté politique et la volonté des
individus. C'est à la fois une action
individuelle. Chacun est parfaitement
capable de décider euh enfin de décider
d'enfin regarder les étiquettes des
produits qu'il achète, de se demander
dans quelles conditions a été produit le
jean qu'il porte et cetera. On peut le
faire. C'est une question de pédagogie.
Il faut à un moment donné aussi
commencer à responsabiliser les
individus et puis ça ne peut pas
marcher. Les individus sont pas les
seuls responsables et c'est pas à eux de
changer le monde tout seul. C'est aussi
par le biais de la politique, par le
biais d'une action collective. Mais
c'est le croisement entre les deux qui
va permettre de changer les choses. Mais
en revanche, je pense que le le minimum
que nous puissions faire, c'est une une
action individuelle pour commencer ne
serait-ce qu'à prendre conscience que
nos chacun de nos gestes, chacun de nos
actes de consommation est un acte
politique. Nous choisissons un système
économique et politique en décidant
d'acheter par exemple des vêtements à
bas prix qui ont été qui ont été
fabriqués dans des conditions ignobles
dans des pays.
Si je vous dis GDPR, ça vous fait penser
à quoi ?
GDPR, ça me fait penser à rien du tout.
Si je vous dis Union européenne,
protection des données, protection de la
vie privée. Oui.
Gafa, est-ce que l'Europe elle est
taillée pour dire bon ben non, ça
suffit, les données, les données
françaises et européennes, elles restent
en France, elles sont protégées par la
loi française, ça suffit. Est-ce qu'elle
est est-ce qu'elle est câblée, équipée
pour faire ça ? Très honnêtement, alors
je ne suis pas ultra spécialiste de ces
sujets-là, mais pour ce que j'en
connais, je pense que l'Union européenne
a été faite pour tout, sauf pour euh
construire une indépendance et une
souveraineté quelle qu'elle soit et sur
ce sujet-là plus que sur les autres. Et
donc il me semble que même s'il y a un
tout début de prise de conscience, nous
avons une telle dépendance
vis-à-vis des gafas que il va falloir
énormément de temps, me semble-t-il pour
permettre de pour pour permettre de
contrer l'espèce d'impérialisme qui
s'est petit à petit imposé. Donc bien
sûr qu'il faut
petit à petit mettre en place des des
comment dire des j'allais dire des
barrières des
arrêter l'hémorragie quoi.
Ouais mais c'est pas c'est déjà pas
grand-chose. Et quand je vois que le que
par exemple le ministère de l'éducation
nationale décide d'autoriser Amazon et
Google à s'introduire dans le marché des
dans le marché éducatif. ce qui va tuer
les petites boîtes françaises qui
étaient sur ce marché-là. Je suis
consterné parce que en plus même si le
ministère de l'éducation nationale nous
explique que tout va bien, il y a un
contrôle et que donc les données des
élèves ne seront absolument pas
utilisées, elles seront tout de même aux
États-Unis. elles seront elles resteront
pas en France les données des élèves.
Donc on a fait entrer le loup dans la
bergerie et ce qui est vrai pour
l'éducation nationale est vrai aussi
pour le ministère de la défense, ce qui
là devient quand même beaucoup plus
grave
comme de la haute trahison
disons
de la haute trahison. Il faudrait encore
avoir conscience que il y a une nation
et des intérêts à servir. Aurélas, je
pense que ce sont des gens qui n'en ont
plus conscience. Donc c'est même pas de
la trahison, c'est de l'incompétence
profonde me semble-t-il et une forme de
naïveté qui qui devient profondément
dangereuse.
Un mot sur l'éducation, la France qui a
eu tellement de médailles field,
le niveau math des Français, tout va
bien. Le niveau éducatif des Français,
tout va bien. Non, vous avez un regard
là-dessus. Vous savez, ça fait des
années que je j'essaie d'expliquer que
le niveau en math est aussi
dramatiquement faible que le niveau en
lecture. Parce que le niveau en lecture
les gens s'en rendent plus ou moins
compte. Ils arrivent à voir que leurs
enfants ont du mal à lire, ne lisent
plus un bouquin et cetera, font des
fautes d'orthographe, des fautes de
grammaire, ne maîtrisent pas la
grammaire, ça se voit.
Il a fallu le temps quand même pour que
ce soit admis et qu'on ait le droit de
le dire sans être traité de réac. Mais
en mathématiques, ça passait totalement
inaperçu jusqu'à présent. Et moi, j'ai
ça fait des années et des années que je
discute avec des gens qui s'intéressent
à ces questions-là, qui travaillent sur
des programmes alternatifs, sur qui
essayent de comprendre comment on
enseigne les mathématiques à des enfants
en maternel et en CP.
Et donc je je me j'essayais d'alerter
depuis des années en disant que le le
justement cette école française
mathématique qui a permis les médailles
field, elle est en train de se casser la
figure. D'ailleurs, il y avait de plus
en plus de professeurs d'université
qui alertaient sur le gouffre désormais
entre des lycéens scientifiques et le ce
qui est demandé ensuite à la fac.
C'estàd que ils expliquent que euh ça
devient dramatique parce que il n'y a
plus aucune capacité à mener un
raisonnement mathématique, c'estàdire à
penser les choses de façon mathématique.
Donc tout ça se prépare dès le dès la
maternelle et l'école primaire. Et donc
il était temps qu'on prenne conscience
du problème. Mais simplement
aujourd'hui, on a un ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui s'appuie sur
les neurosciences, sur le travail de
Stanislas De
qui démontre que par exemple le la
répétition est nécessaire à la
mémorisation. Enfin, je suis très
contente mais ça fait quand même de
siècles qu'on le sait. Il aurait suffi
de ne pas le nier sur les quatre
dernières décennies. C'est vrai que moi
je connais en effet beaucoup de gens qui
expliquent depuis des années que oui, la
mémorisation passe par la répétition, la
répétition, la mécanique, les exercices
mécaniques qui permettent d'assimiler un
processus de pensée. Bon, tout ça, on le
sait. Bon, s'il faut les neurosciences
pour le démontrer, tant mieux. Mais vous
voyez que toute la pensée pédagogique a
été détruite. Toute celle parce que sur
les mathématiques par exemple, là aussi
vous avez des recherches sur le la
pédagogie et la la l'apprentissage des
mathématiques depuis le début du 19e
siècle. Et ce qui enfin les les
connaissances qu'on avait c'était que un
enfant doit euh d'abord manipuler des
objets, des quantités, des longueurs. Il
doit comparer des longueurs, il doit
peser des objets avec une vieille
balance. Tout ça lui permet de
visualiser les quantités, de comprendre
les rapports entre ces quantités. Il
faut introduire très très tôt les quatre
opérations fondamentales : addition,
soustraction, multiplication et
division. tout simplement parce que ça
fonctionne ensemble et parce que pour
comprendre par exemple le le chiffre 534
et bien l'enfant doit tout de suite
comprendre que c'est 5 x 100 + 3 x 10 +
4. Donc il mélange euh addition et
multiplication. Donc il faut les
apprendre ensemble et très tôt. Ça ça a
été détruit parce que on apprenait en
France jusqu'à dans les années 60 les
quatre opérations fondamentales dép. Ça
a été supprimé dans les années 70 avec
les mathématiques modernes. Ça n'a
jamais été rétabli. C'est que on n'est
jamais revenu à cette manipulation, à
cette réflexion sur la façon dont on
passe du concret à l'abstrait.
C'est tout ça qu'il faut retravailler.
Ça va prendre du temps parce que il faut
une formation des professeurs qui pour
l'instant n'existe pas. Est-ce que ça
fait pas 4 décennies qu'on est en train
de d'arroser un terreau de crétin avec
des méthodes éducatives qui sont euh pas
effective et efficaces et que maintenant
ce terreau de crétin se doit gérer une
situation inextricable entre l'écologie,
l'économie, la démographie et tout un
tas de facteurs avidissants et
débilitant. Et est-ce que ce ter va
pouvoir se réveiller avec des méthodes
un peu alternatives comme l'école
Montessori, l'école démocratique et des
choses comme ça ou est-ce que ça y est,
on est parti pour aller faire une lente
glissade avec nos copains qui ont pas
été formés correctement par une école
qui était démissionnaire ?
Je pense que alors il y a des
beaucoup de recherches pédagogiques, les
écoles Montessori, les choses comme ça,
c'est très très bien. Sauf que pour
l'instant ça marche sur un tout petit
lot d'élèves
qui ont avec des parents. Et c'est ça,
c'est tout le paradoxe parce qu'il faut
savoir que quand même Maria Montessori,
elle travaillait avec des enfants des
banlieux de Rome pauvres et en général
battus, martyrisé, voilà et que
aujourd'hui on utilise cette pédagogie
pour des enfants rois de milieu
ultrabourgeois.
Je suis pas certaine que ce soit
exactement le but. Et donc il y a
peut-être d'autres manières. Je trouve
plus intéressantes les recherches que
peut mener par exemple le grip, le
groupe de recherche interdisciplinaires
sur les programmes. Ce sont des instites
qui depuis des années travaille, il y a
des des manuels scolaires euh si et si
vous les regardez, ils sont très
intéressants. Faites la comparaison.
Vous prenez un manuel de mathématiques
normale utilisé dans les écoles
françaises de CP et le manuel du gripe.
Le manuel utilisé dans les CP actuels,
vous n'y comprenez rien. Vous êtes
incapable de faire cours vous-même à
votre gamin avec ça. C'est vous
comprenez même pas l'intérêt pédagogique
des exercices. Vous prenez le manuel du
grippe, vous comprenez tout de suite.
C'estd qu'on aborde avec des parts de
tarte les moitiés, les tiers. Donc on
entre directement dans la dans la
multiplication, la division et cetera et
vous pouvez le faire vous-même. C'est
logique, c'est progressif. Bon, donc ça
veut dire que et ce sont des gens qui
ont travaillé à ça, qui ont réfléchi à
la meilleure manière de faire passer par
exemple comment on explique le périmètre
à un enfant avec une ficelle, une boîte
de conserve pour lui montrer le rapport
entre le périmètre, le diamètre en lui
faisant mesurer. Bon, voilà, toutes ces
choses-là, ça se pense parce que
enseigner, c'est un métier, ça s'invente
pas. Il y a un savoir-faire, c'est même
c'est même un artisanat en fait et avec
un savoir-faire avec une pâte. Bon, le
problème c'est qu'en effet, on a détruit
des compétences et qu'aujourd'hui les
jeunes instituteurs sont eux-mêmes les
produits de ce système- là. Donc comment
on fait pour rétablir ça ? Ça va prendre
au bamo 10 ou 15 ans pour vraiment
reconstruire toutes ces compétences.
Donc il y a urgence. Il y a d'autant
plus urgence que pendant ce temps-là des
gens qui ne sont pas formés, des élèves
qui petit à petit n'ont pas les clés
pour maîtriser la langue, pour maîtriser
la pensée mathématique, bah ce sont des
gens qui sont d'autant plus poreux à
toutes les formes d'aliénation, à toutes
les formes de pulsion. Or
d'astrurfing aussi,
pardon.
D'astroturfing.
Oui. Oui. Bah oui. Oui. Tout tout. Mais
c'est c'est simplement que vous voyez le
drame, c'est je suis pas complotiste, je
pense pas que il y ait une volonté
d'abrutir les masses pour mieux les
manipuler. Je pense que c'est une
conjonction de facteurs. Disons qu'en
tout cas, ça dérange pas l'abrutissement
des masses ne dérange pas le système.
Bien au contraire, c'est et que au
contraire le principe de ce système
consumériste, c'est de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait le moins possible de
raisonnement de de rationalité pour
qu'il y ait le plus possible de pulsion.
Le problème étant que une société qui ne
fonctionne que avec des individus
mu par leur pulsion est une société
travaillée par des forces centrifuges et
qui petit à petit se détruit et se
délite. Et nous le voyons aujourd'hui,
c'est-à-dire que nous allons en payer
les conséquences. Ça marche pas de une
société d'individus
consumériste. C'est une société de
cauchemar parce qu'il n'y a plus de
communauté politique, parce qu'il n'y a
plus de capacité à accepter l'autre et à
vivre avec lui, parce qu'il n'y a plus
de capacité de débat politique.
Donc la seule façon de tenir cela, c'est
d'aller vers une forme de totalitarisme
doux pour euh empêcher les formes de
violence qui peuvent naître dans ce dans
ce système-là.
Donc là aujourd'hui, nous en sommes
clairement là. C'est-à-dire que nous
sommes dans une dans cette forme de
totalitarisme soft où on essaie de
canaliser les les pulsions qu'on a
provoqué pour permettre à la machine
économique de fonctionner.
On canalise de crétin maintenant.
Bah oui, oui, on les on canaly en
donnant toujours plus de
d'espoir de posséder et de de se de
s'accomplir dans la possession d'objets.
On essaie de gérer la frustration née de
du spectacle de la consommation par ceux
qui ne peuvent pas y accéder. On essaie
de
réguler en dictant des comportements et
en expliquant aux gens ce qu'ils doivent
faire par une forme de catéchisme
qui est le contraire de la pensée
démocratique. Enfin, c'est tout ça qui
est en train de de de se passer. Donc la
la seule façon de contrer tout ça, c'est
de c'est petit à petit d'essayer de
reconstruire de la rationalité, de la
pensée. Donc ça passe bien sûr par
l'école, ça passe par la maîtrise de la
langue, par la maîtrise de la du
vocabulaire, de la grammaire,
de l'intelligence artificielle.
Alors l'intelligence artificielle c'est
un outil. D'abord, je
je crois profondément
à la pensée humaniste et en particulier
à celle de Rabel sans science sans
conscience n'est que ruine de l'âme.
Donc si l'intelligence est artificielle,
elle n'a pas de conscience. Donc cette
intelligence artificielle, elle est bien
créée par quelqu'un. Et je pense que la
question est de savoir qui est ce
quelqu'un et quels sont ses buts et
comment il est contrôlé démocratiquement
aussi. Donc l'intelligence artificielle
en soi, ça n'est rien. C'est le système
qui l'a produit qui me semble
intéressant et qu'il faut penser.
Oui.
Mais pour l'instant s'il s'agit de nous
faire croire que par l'intelligence
artificielle, on va combler tous les
défauts de cette société, non, ça n'est
pas vrai. Bien au contraire, on risque
de créer un cauchemar encore plus grand.
D'abord parce que bon alors si on en
vient uniquement à la question de
l'éducation, moi je veux bien qu'on se
mette à rêver que par une puce
introduite dans le cerveau, on va
enseigner directement les langues
étrangères, l'histoire et que ça va être
formidable et qu'il y aura plus
d'efforts à faire. L'être humain se
comment dire progresse et se construit
par l'effort, il se construit par la
main, il se construit par les cinq sens.
Et c'est ça qu'oublie un petit peu les
les les modernistes fantasmatiques
actuels,
nouveau religieux.
Mais bien sûr, c'est là aussi c'est une
forme de c'est c'est une forme de
religiosité. C'est-à-dire que on croit
au lendemain qui chante, on croit à une
eschatologie où enfin l'homme se sera
débarrassé de ses faiblesse et de ses de
ses défauts. C'est très dangereux de
vouloir penser la perfection de l'homme.
Je En général, ça aboutit à des au
totalitarismes les plus violents. Donc
moi je crois qu'il faut prendre l'homme
avec ses limites, avec ses faiblesses et
que c'est parce qu'il a des limites et
des faiblesses
qu'il peut aussi
construire une société qui soit une
société vivable parce que c'est une
société où chacun respecte les
faiblesses de l'autre.
Bon, on a quelques petites questions
d'internet, on les prend en vraque comme
ça.
Comment voyez-vous les médias sur du
long terme ? Point d'interrogation.
Votre vision du monde dans 10 ans, dans
20 ans.
Les médias et les journalistes sont-ils
prêts à être fact checké en ligne ?
Euh Capitaine Fact, à mon avis, il
connaît pas. Comment Internet modifie le
journalisme ? Financement de certains
médias par Facebook et la dernière notre
préférée, la Marie Ruana.
[rires]
Alors pour ce qui est de la question du
des journalistes et de leur fact
checking, je vais je les prends pas dans
l'ordre mais je vais essayer de toutes
les les faire.
Euh
encore une fois, la question du fact
checking, elle est très intéressante si
on en comprend les limites. C'est-à-dire
que un journaliste ne parle pas que des
faits, il faut pas croire.
il
donne des faits et il est nécessaire que
ces faits soient vérifiés, mais il donne
aussi les lecture et il donne aussi une
manière de penser, une réflexion sur
l'articulation de ces faits entre eux.
Donc ça tout ne relève pas du fact
checking. On va pas sauver le
journalisme par le fact checking. En
revanche, on va sauver le journalisme
par le pluralisme qui va permettre de
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
opinions et des visions du monde et des
valeurs soient représenté et puisse
débattre de façon apaisée. La démocratie
c'est le on va dire c'est le
l'engueulade civilisée. C'est-à-dire que
on n'est capable de pas être d'accord.
On peut être farouchement en opposition
sur certains sujets, mais on se le dit
entre êtres humains civilisés, on se le
dit poliment en argumentant et en et en
surtout en argumentant sans jamais taper
en dessous de la ceinture, c'est-à-dire
sans jamais laisser entendre que l'autre
n'est pas légitime ou que il est un
salot même si il se présente comme un
type bien. Voyez, c'est ça.
On a perdu la vraie joueur oratoire.
Oui, bien sûr. À partir du moment où on
refuse cette idée que on va débattre
argument contre argument, honnêtement,
voilà, on perd la capacité, c'est pas
seulement de l'ajoute oratoire, encore
une fois, il y a un enjeu de il y a un
enjeu politique majeur là-dedans. C'est
la capacité à faire émerger le bien
commun à travers l'opposition des idées,
des visions du monde. Or, le journalisme
doit participer à ça. C'est pour ça que
je je crois pas qu'on va sauver le
journalisme par l'effet, l'objectivité.
Mais l'objectivité, ça n'existe pas. À
partir du moment où vous racontez un
fait, vous êtes déjà dans la
subjectivité. Alors, pour que un
journaliste puisse faire tout son
travail correctement, il doit déjà
maîtriser le langage. C'est-à-dire qu'il
doit avoir conscience de sa propre
subjectivité dans son langage. Il il
doit savoir que le choix de tel mot
plutôt que tel autre implique une
lecture des faits. Et donc, il doit le
faire en toute conscience. C'est-à-dire
que il doit pas se employer un mot pour
un autre en s'imaginant que ça n'a pas
d'importance. Touche pas à mon poste. Ça
vous fait penser à quoi ? [soupir]
Euh, ça me fait penser à
comment on a
Ça me fait penser à l'ensemble de ce qui
aujourd'hui euh
construit un système consumériste où la
télévision, la publicité, la grande
distribution fonctionne en boucle.
C'est-à-dire que on est dans euh comment
dire dans cette phrase de Patrick Lelet
qui résume l'époque "Mon travail est de
mettre de vendre à Coca-Cola du temps de
cerveau humain disponible." Bon ben tant
qu'on concevra les rapports entre
télévision, publicité et grande
distribution de cette façonlà, on sera
dans l'aliénation.
Donc
c'est du pain et des jeux.
Oui, bien sûr que c'est du pain et des
jeux. Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Et ça n'est pas comment dire ça n'est
pas jeté le probre sur le divertissement
que de dire ça dans la mesure où je
disait tout à l'heure que le
il faut aller il faut aussi aller
chercher les gens là où ils sont et que
je j'ai eu des débats moi au moment où
j'ai accepté d'aller on n'est pas couché
au moment où j'ai accepté d'aller bosser
chez Hardisson. J'ai eu des débats avec
des des gens que je respecte
profondément et qui me disaient c'est du
divertissement.
La question c'est ce qu'on y fait aussi
quand je suis chez Hardisson et que je
fais un sujet sur les
hacking social,
j'aurais pas cette prétention mais en
tout cas j'essaie de faire mon travail
et de le faire de façon à faire passer
un message. Voyez le quand je lutte
contre le l'industrialisation de
l'agriculture en essayant de faire
comprendre aux gens les enjeux,
l'antibiorésistante ce qui est un sujet
absolument majeur parce que ça peut
provoquer des catastrophes sanitaires.
Bon bah, je fais ça dans une émission de
divertissement mais c'est à une heure de
grande écoute où il y a des gens qui
vont écouter et s'il y en a quelques-uns
qui tout à coup se disent ça c'est un
sujet important, je vais aller me
renseigner là-dessus et ben j'ai gagné.
C'est je pense que j'ai j'ai au moins
essayé de faire quelque chose, c'est
tout. Je Mais évidemment que on peut
aussi considérer que c'est une caution
au système. On peut oui, c'est un débat
qu'il faut avoir en permanence et qu'il
faut avoir avec soi-même en permanence.
Comment Internet a modifié le
journalisme ?
Alors
hélas pas enfin pas en bien, c'estàdire
que internet aurait pu modifier le
journalisme en bien dans le sens où euh
il y a une
c'est une c'est un défi qui est lancé et
le le fait que les gens aillent vers des
médias alternatifs sur internet, c'est
parce qu'il y a eu un naufrage des
médias
des des médias classiques. Donc
simplement
tu es sur des médias russes. Oui, ben
bien sûr, mais tout tout. Il y a une il
y a une comment dire, il y a une volonté
de la part du public d'aller chercher
l'information euh là où elle peut être
parce qu'elle n'est plus là où elle
devrait être
ou là où ça sent moins le rond rond.
Voilà, là où ils ont l'impression qu'on
ne leur ment pas. Le problème c'est que
du coup
certains acceptent n'importe quoi du
moment que ce ne sont pas les médias
alternatifs et c'est là qu'on passe de
la question du enfin qu'on passe de
médias alternatifs à parfois certains
délires qu'on peut trouver sur des sur
des sites internet ou donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut travailler toujours à faire
en sorte que
il y ait une interrogation sur la
qualité de l'inform formation sur les
sources. Voilà. Mais c'est au public de
juger. Moi, je ne suis pas pour un une
interdiction de telle ou telle de je
trouve profondément dangereux qu'on
puisse d'en haut décider ce qui relève
d'un bon média ou d'un mauvais. Il y a
aujourd'hui une recherche d'information
alternative de la part d'un public qui a
l'impression qu'on lui ment. Bon ben,
arrêtons de lui donner l'impression
qu'on lui ment et déjà on évitera que
certains aillent lire n'importe quoi sur
internet parce qu'il y a le meilleur et
le pire sur internet. Donc la question
c'est l'éducation du public et la le
pluralisme et la volonté d'aller au bout
et de poser toutes les questions de la
part des journalistes. Donc c'est ça que
devrait leur inspirer internet. Et là au
contraire ça leur inspire des espèces de
de comment dire de logoré permanente sur
le complotisme qui a gagné
le la France. Je suis très frappée par
ça. C'est on on a trouvé un nouvel
ennemi, c'est le complotisme. Intérieur.
Voilà. Et donc on fait des
le penseur des viants. C'est ça.
C'est ça. C'est ça. Il y a des gens qui
pensent mal et il y a des méchants qui
essayent de les faire penser mal avec
des fake news. Par exemple, le la
l'étude de la fondation Jean Jorè sur le
complotisme. Elle est quand même
extraordinaire cette étude. C'estàd que
tout est mis sur le même plan. des trucs
en effet totalement délirants et des
questions qu'on peut tout à fait
légitimement se poser. Je ne vois
vraiment pas en quoi il est complotiste
par exemple de répondre oui à la
question pensez-vous que euh Al-Qaïda et
Daesh a pu avoir des liens avec les
services secrets occidentaux ?
Ça a été
enfin pardon mais c'est c'est une
évidence enfin c'est la base. Et ben non
c'est jugé comme complotiste. Donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut
dire que toute pensée, toute réflexion,
toute question qu'on se pose sur les on
va dire les les vérités qui nous sont
servies en question la remise en
question de la parole officielle du K
d'orsa. C'est ça.
Voilà, à peu près. C'est ça. C'estàd que
en gros, il ne faut pas remettre en
cause la doxa. C'est pas comme ça qu'on
va sauver les médias et le journalisme.
La Marie Ruana.
La Marie Ruana, c'est c'est un des
sujets que j'ai traité chez Hardisson
d'ailleurs et là aussi j'ai comment dire
je continue à penser que et je sais
c'est pas pas je pense je sais que le
haschich est dangereux que ça provoque
des dégâts absolument terribles sur sur
certains organismes, que ça détruit des
neurones que ça détruit la capacité de
concentration et même la volonté que ça
peut provoquer des dépressions, voir des
schizophrénies. Pour autant, je pense
que la façon dont on traite le problème
aujourd'hui a abouti à un échec total.
Et donc, j'en suis à me dire que une
légalisation
de du cannabis
euh serait la seule solution.
[grognement] Je prétends pas en être
sûr, je peux me tromper, mais autant bon
les amendes telles qu'elles sont mises
en place, c'est une fouesse. Ça permet
juste de rapporter un peu d'argent mais
le problème reste entier. la
dépénalisation, le problème resterait
totalement entier puisqu'on continuerait
à alimenter des trafics et à confronter
des jeunes gens avec des caïdes qui
tiennent des des quartiers. Donc je vois
pas l'intérêt. En revanche, une
légalisation et là c'est mon côté
régulateur qui intervient, c'estàd une
légalisation avec monopole de l'État qui
contrôle toutes les filières et qui a
qui met en place un fonctionnement un
peu comme pour la CIT.
Je me dis que ça peut permettre
de sauver les puralistes.
Voilà, de sauver les puralistes
accessoirement. Avant tout de
savoir ce qu'il y a dans le cannabis
qu'on achète. Euh donc d'éviter les
cochonneries qui sont foutues dedans.
Donc c'est une question de santé
publique. Ça permet de mettre en place
une véritable prévention parce que pour
l'instant comme c'est interdit, on fait
pas de prévention. Donc il y a rien, il
y a aucun discours notamment à
destination des jeunes pour leur
expliquer à quel point c'est dangereux
comme l'alcool.
Comme voilà comme l'alcool. Exactement.
Ensuite c'est je me dis que ça
permettrait aussi de [__] un énorme
coup de pied dans la fourmilière,
c'est-à-dire de casser les trafics.
Alors évidemment ça nécessite de la part
d'un pouvoir politique qui prendrait
cette décision d'être capable d'en
assumer les conséquences. C'est-à-dire
que je pense que ça provoquerait des
remous dans certains quartiers. Et quand
je dis des remous, c'est un euphémisme
total.
Est-ce que vous pensez que ce commerce
qui est maintenu dans la prohibition
permet de maintenir les banlieux au
calme ?
Oh oui, là on achète la paix sociale, je
pense. On achète en partie la paix
sociale en se disant que bon ça ça
confine le problème mais qu'après tout
ça évite une explosion. Donc légaliser,
ça obligerait aussi à réfléchir à la
façon dont on donne du travail à tous
ces gens-là, à la façon dont on
reconstruit une économie qui soit une
véritable économie euh saine à la façon
dont on recrée du lien social. Voilà.
Alors, c'est la méthode un peu brutale,
hein, de l'égaliser d'un coup et de et
de voir ce que ça donne. Mais ça
obligerait les politiques à assumer
parce que pour l'instant, il y a quand
même une hypocrisie absolue. Quand
j'entends des maires qui disent "Ah oui,
mais quand il y a une descente de police
dans tel quartier où il y a du trafic,
on voit que certains enfants vont plus à
la cantine dans les jours qui viennent
parce que les familles ont plus de quoi
payer." Je veux dire, on accepte ça.
On on accepte que des enfants
grandissent avec l'idée que leur seule
façon de s'en sortir dans la vie, c'est
de participer à ces trafic, que
finalement ça devient une référence. On
accepte qu'ils en soient à dire à leur
prof de toute façon euh je peux me faire
ce que tu gagnes en un mois, moi je me
le fais en quelques jours et cetera.
C'est-à-dire à valoriser une économie
qui est une économie
illégale et de d'oppression. Donc je
pense que il faut absolument cesser
cette cette hypocrisie qui pourrit la
vie de certaines de de la majorité des
gens qui vivent dans ces quartiers euh
qui les fait vivre parfois sous la
terreur et que c'est inacceptable de de
se dire que certains citoyens sous
prétexte qu'ils ont la malchance de
vivre dans des quartiers qui sont des
quartiers populaires, qui sont les plus
pauvres et bien doivent supporter cette
terreur. Donc pour toutes ces raisons
là, je me dis qu'une légalisation
permettrait de oui de casser tout ça et
d'obliger à à traiter réellement les
problèmes.
[soupir]
On arrive à la fin de notre émission.
Euh avant de vous poser la question euh
classique et traditionnelle du conseil
pour les jeunes générations,
en préparant l'émission, j'en ai deux
trois qui sont venus me voir concernant
la polémique autour de votre salaire
des 27400 € si mes souvenirs sont bons.
Est-ce que vous avez un mot à leur
répondre ? Oui, je peux leur répondre
que d'abord euh c'est ce que j'ai touché
pendant 10 mois à un moment où Europain
m'avait demandé de faire en plus de
cette revue de presse qui me demandait
euh oui beaucoup de travail. Oui.
Levends,
c'est
je confirme 4h du matin.
Voilà. Donc pendant 10 mois européen en
plus de cette revue de presse et parce
qu'elle marchait très bien, que les
audiences étaient excellentes, m'avait
demandé de faire un débat quotidien tous
les jours à 18h30 plus Méia police, une
émission d'un heure tous les samedis.
Donc c'est du travail. Alors évidemment
le salaire est indécent pour tous ceux
qui gagnent le SMIC ou à peine plus.
Voilà. Et que des gens qui travaillent
et qui gagnent très peu, il y en a
plein.
Les salaires dans l'audiovisuel
euh sont sans commune mesure avec ce
qu'il y a dans le reste du pays. Et
c'est un système injuste. C'est vrai. En
même temps, pour ma part, quand je suis
arrivée dans avec mon petit salaire de
presse écrite au début, on m'a dit
salaire de presse écrite au moment où
j'ai été embauchée à Europe, 1,
j'étais euh voyons, je sais plus, je
sais plus, j'ai commencé à Marianne à
2000 € et petit à petit, j'ai progressé
quand je suis arrivée au Figaro Euh
j'étais j'étais déjà payé mieux et
voilà, j'ai commencé donc je sais plus
exactement mais on est autour de
de 2000 balles quand même.
Alors plus quand je suis arrivée à quand
quand j'étais au Figaro plus que ça. Et
du coup j'avais ce salaire là au début
pour ma revue de presse parce que j'ai
été embauchée. On m'a demandé mais
mais vous voulez être payé combien ? Et
moi gentiment et bêtement, j'ai dit
"Mais je voudrais ne pas y perdre par
rapport à ce que je gagnais au Figaro."
Voilà. Et c'est après que j'ai compris
ce que c'était que les salaires de
l'audiovisuel et que c'était pas du tout
pareil. Donc j'ai arrêté de négocier
moi-même toute seule et euh voilà, j'ai
et donc je petit à petit, comme les
audiences étaient très bonnes, j'ai été
augmenté jusqu'à ce prix-là. Oui, et je
comprends que ce prix-là soit considéré
comme indécent.
Euh les salaire des autres journalistes
en vue euh sont euh du même ordre ou
plus. Euh
qui ?
Bon, je suis sortie dans la presse,
voyons. Et euh et je Europin n'est pas
philanthrope, hein. Ils m'ont pas donner
ça juste par gentillesse. De même
d'ailleurs queils m'ont jamais donné
quoi que ce soit par gentillesse. Mais
parce que les audiences étaient très
bonnes. De tenir les journalistes, de
leur filer des salaires mirobolants pour
éviter qu'il morde la main qui nourrit.
Bah, vu la façon dont j'ai été euh
j'ai été remercié, on va dire, euh je
pense pas que qui que ce soit est
considéré que j'étais tenue.
Peut-être pas assez, je ne sais pas.
Mais c'est disons que pour moi, je enfin
je fais mon travail comme je crois
devoir le faire, c'est-à-dire le plus
honnêtement possible et en
essayant de de faire passer des valeurs
et des idées qui sont les miennes.
Encore une fois, ce salaire est
indécent. J'essaie de
j'essaie qu'il ne soit pas donné pour
rien. C'est-à-dire que je bosse, je fais
pas je j'arrive pas les mains dans les
poches. Euh et
c'est ça ne m'empêche pas, ce salaire ne
m'a pas empêché de dire ce que je
pensais de de l'ensemble du système
économique tel qu'il est. C'est-à-dire
que alors bien sûr, je vais dire à
partir de quel de quel salaire il
fallait que je refuse ? à partir de quel
salaire il fallait que je dise "Écoutez,
c'est vrai, ne me donnez pas cet argent,
donnez-le aux actionnaires de du groupe
la garder". Parce que c'est ça le si
j'avais pas accepté ce salaire-là, si je
l'avais pas pris, l'argent il était pas
pour payer euh la Dactilo qui euh
travaillait avec moi et dont j'aurais
préféré qu'elle soit mieux payée, elle
aurait rien gagné. Le technicien non
plus, rien du tout. En revanche, les
actionnaires du groupe, oui. Donc
h et là, c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait
changer un système. Et je ne connais pas
grand monde qui aurait dit "Non, non,
écoutez, je n'en veux pas."
un avis sur les journalistes qui font
des ménages.
Ça en revanche c'est un autre problème.
Oui, les journalistes qui font des
ménages parce que quand on fait des
ménages là on petit à petit on se met en
on construit des dépendances, on
construit des amitiés
et là ça pose problème.
Comment vous voyez les médias dans 10
ans, dans 20 ans ?
Tout dépend si les médias réussissent à
comprendre le message qu'il aurait
adressé par les citoyens.
Je pense que
ce qu'on entend partout, c'est une
colère absolument immense contre les
journalistes et contre les médias en
général. colère [grognement] que je
pense légitime. Donc il faut l'entendre
et il faut essayer de comprendre comment
faire ce travail le mieux possible
et comment euh essayer de maintenir ce
qui fait la valeur ajoutée d'un
journaliste par rapport à n'importe qui
qui peut donner une information. C'est
encore une fois qu'un journaliste ne
doit pas se contenter de donner une
information que lui a donné quelqu'un
qui avait intérêt à ce qu'elle soit
publiée. Euh un journaliste, c'est pas
ça. C'est quelqu'un qui enquête, qui
cherche à comprendre, qui cherche à
faire comprendre les choses. Euh si si
les médias ne comprennent pas que il y a
besoin de contenu, qu'il y a besoin
d'exigence, qui a besoin de
de pluralisme,
petit à petit, ils perdront encore un
petit peu plus de leur voix et de leur
crédit. Cela dit, ça laisse toute la
place à des médias alternatifs. Le
problème, c'est si ces médias
alternatifs deviennent des espèces de
petites niches qui ne permettent pas de
de faire se parler l'ensemble des
citoyens et qui ne permettent pas de
construire ce fameux débat démocratique
qui est indispensable. Si chacun va vers
un média qui lui dit ce qu'il veut
entendre et que chacun reste dans son
petit coin idéologique,
alors il n'y a plus de société possible.
On a reçu récemment Pablo Servigne sur
la collapsologie. Ça vous parle ?
Non, ça c'est un domaine que je ne
connais pas très bien.
L'effondrement d'un système
dû à des des fondamentaux qui sont plus
soutenables. Ça vous parle pas ?
Si, dit comme ça. Oui,
je connaissais pas le terme
collapsologie.
C'est c'est tout nouveau. Ça vient de
sortir. C'est c'est pas mal. Euh donc un
conseil pour les jeunes générations et
on arrive à la fin. un conseil pour les
jeunes générations,
j'allais dire tout simplement de
d'essayer de
de se construire toutes les formes de
résistance
au système, c'est-à-dire de
voyez dans dans le le livre que j'ai
écrit Changé la vie, il y a il y a une
partie de réflexion politique sur le les
institutions, la démocratie, le système
économique et cetera. comment on va
pouvoir ensemble politiquement
reconstruire des euh des des
institutions véritablement démocratiques
et une société véritablement
démocratique. Et puis il y a une
deuxième partie sur la dimension
individuelle. Comment on fait pour
changer sa propre vie ? c'est-à-dire
pour essayer justement de s'émanciper de
ce système. Et ça passe par la capacité
à tout simplement à regarder le monde, à
réapprendre
à vivre voilà les à s'émerveiller à à
être au monde ici et maintenant,
c'est-à-dire
à se à comprendre la beauté des choses,
à comprendre le geste. Alors, je j'aime
pas ce terme sérénipité puisque c'est un
terme qui pour moi enfin qui ne me parle
absolument pas qui est une espèce de
néologisme.
Je pense surtout à une forme d'humanisme
qui comprend que l'être humain est un
être qui se construit par ses cinq sens
et que et par la tout simplement la
plénitude dans son environnement. Ça
nécessite d'aller rechercher la beauté
là où elle est, d'être capable de la
sentir et de la regarder. Ça nécessite
de se de pouvoir se regarder en face,
c'est-à-dire d'avoir conscience de ses
limites et de les accepter. Ça nécessite
de se trouver des engagements et de
d'essayer de trouver tout ce qui va
permettre de dépasser le cadre de sa
propre vie, c'est-à-dire de combattre
pour des causes, pour des idées, pour ne
pas être uniquement enfermé sur soi, sur
son nombrile. Ça nécessite donc de
d'essayer en tout domaine de de
d'assumer ses responsabilités. On
parlait tout à l'heure de la de tout
acte de consommation qui est un choix
politique. Et bien s'imposer dans la
mesure du possible d'être en en
cohérence avec ces idées. On disait tout
à l'heure, on parlait de de mon salaire.
Oui, je j'ai gagné beaucoup. Je gagne
encore très bien ma vie par rapport à de
la plupart des Français. Et qu'est-ce
que je fais de ça qui est en effet qui
me fait profiter d'un système dont je
trouve qu'il est injuste ? [grognement]
Et bien, j'essaie de tout simplement
dans chacun de mes actes de consommation
de d'aller systématiquement vers ce qui
va recréer de l'emploi, protéger un
système économique plus plus
juste et mieux construit.
Oui aussi plus patriote, c'est-à-dire
oui plus patriote dans le sens où euh je
pense qu'il faut préserver des paysage,
préserver un mode de vie, préserver une
façon d'être au monde telle que l'a
construite la France. Ça passe par une
agriculture qui soit une agriculture
paysane. Donc je vais systématiquement
aller consacrer une part plus importante
de mon budget à cela. Je quand je dois
choisir h ne serait-ce que un produit,
un artisan, je regarde comment il agit.
Je voilà, c'est-à-dire que c'est une
façon d'orienter mon budget. J'ai la
chance de pouvoir le faire. Tout le
monde peut pas se payer des produits
bios. Tout le monde peut pas euh faire
appel à des artisans français, acheter
des produits fabriqués en France. Moi,
je veux le faire et ben je le fais
systématiquement parce que ça préserve
des emplois, parce que ça ça crée de la
richesse ici autour et que ça va
permettre petit à petit si tous ceux qui
peuvent le faire le font, ça va
peut-être permettre un tout petit peu de
réorienter le système économique. Voilà,
donc c'est ma façon d'essayer d'être en
cohérence avec ce que je crois. C'est
une de mes façons en plus de me battre
pour des idées pour des voilà pour un
système que je pense plus juste.
On va pouvoir lancer notre marque de
avec vous Mine France. Oui.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Un conseil euh
lire et vivre et retrouver euh un lien
avec la nature, c'est-à-dire tout
simplement aller de temps en temps
regarder un brin d'herbe poussé,
regarder l'effet du froid et du gel sur
un champ. Voilà, il y a rien.
Une bonne bouteille de peinard. Voilà.
Et partager. avec avec des des amis et
en parler tout simplement parce que
c'est surtout ça, c'est pour ça que je
disais lire aussi, c'està-dire maîtriser
les mots parce que en fait l'être humain
est un est un être qui à travers ces ces
cinq sens crée du vécu et ce vécu, il en
parle. C'est par les mots que ce vécu
reste et devient ce qui nous construit,
ce qui fait notre mémoire. Donc oui,
ouvrir une bonne bouteille de vin,
partager un repas et parler de cette
expérience et la partager. C'est tout ça
la vie euh dans ce cas-là de de plus
beau et c'est ça qui va qui permet à
chacun de se sentir exister et de et
tout simplement d'être
de profiter un petit peu de ce de ce
monde. Voilà.
Natacha Polonie, merci.
Merci beaucoup. Couper.